i had a great weekend
you were in san francisco walking around
i did have to thank you for that by the
way italian tours
it was a lot of fun it was a
and um we don't talk about it that much
but you've been really great to me over
the past couple years and it's i've been
you're a great man well i've been
thinking because we're hitting 300 on
wednesday and
and i told you that we were thinking
about going to san francisco uh for
anniversary but hotel rooms are just
insane up there
and you were very you didn't you didn't
tell me right but you gave me some extra
money so i could go for my anniversary
so i think we look we really had a great
time we uh
we're a family here and
sometimes i don't i felt guilty but i'm
not taking you to boston the plane
tickets were so expensive oh they're
crazy so i gave you the same amount for
the plane ticket you know
um sometimes you want to do something
for somebody
something nice and you know what you
know like i'm not a [ __ ] i'm a [ __ ]
but i'm not a [ __ ] okay
i know sometimes if i'm gonna buy you
something for 200 right i'm gonna go you
know what what's lee gonna need more
does he want 200 for some stupid [ __ ]
new england shirt or does he want two
and a half to go get his nice [ __ ]
dinner with his wife that he could both
enjoy you follow me that's the type of
guy i am so sometimes when i see like i
don't get people a lot of [ __ ] but
sometimes i see something and i go that
fits that person's needs i'm going to
get up in them and i'll look at the
price stick and go what does this person
really need from me does he need this
stupid [ __ ] football shirt or a hat
that i was going to get you one time for
300
or do i give him the 250 and let them go
enjoy
you following me that's the type of
[ __ ] i am so
uh
and it's nice to get a hat from time to
time i'm not saying nothing oh no it's
great but it's also like you part of me
yeah part of me for a second was like
ooh
i have all these bills i could pay some
bills but then i was like she really
wants to go and i want to go we had a
great time it was listen you put work in
i'm not a big 10-day [ __ ] vacation
guy in a cruise no but i tell you what a
change of scenery
does the show great sometimes
lily i'm talking about
honey we got no money but i have enough
to take you to san diego to costa mesa
to get a a sandwich and just to walk on
the boardwalk how many people like that
you know people yearn to do something
like that yeah sometimes it's the
simplest things lee
i've always been into the simplest
things
you know and sometimes you have such a
better time
some of the best times i've had was when
i was broke and
making the best out of 18
yeah you know making the best out of 18
with somebody we didn't really do a lot
of crazy things up there we stayed in a
nice hotel but other than that we we we
went and did one of those um tandem
bikes not the ones that are like
two-seat like back and back but it's
like you sit side by side that was fun
we walked around like the hippie hill
have you been in the golden gate park
[ __ ] yeah they worked across the street
from golden gate park really in 1985
what were you doing bartending
oh wow i hate that i had a bar called
rocking robin's across from mcdonald's
on the corner
did you see that mcdonald's i don't want
to hate ash berry burger king we went to
haiti ashbury and there was there's that
ben and jerry's i went to that record
store writing it right like a block down
and i got two richard pryor albums
and i took a star before i went it was a
lot of fun it was just like when am i
gonna be up there san francisco is a
very neat city that
everybody should see it was my first
it was the first big city i saw when i
got out of new york and i immediately
fell in love oh it's one thing i gotta
tell you
i wanted you to stay at a nice hotel
because
that's a bad place to stay at a bad
hotel i'm not putting the city down or
anything the tenderloin all that [ __ ]
down there that shit's real yeah we
walked by ladies and gentlemen that
shit's real and i as a young man i was
up there at at the age of 20 and i saw
more blood in a summer than i saw my
whole [ __ ] life in new york city
really
right by the old original joes i saw a
guy getting stabbed once and the brown
the blood was [ __ ] black
like he was clinging to [ __ ] life you
know i saw another guy get stabbed i saw
a fist fight with sticks one time when i
was walk because i used to take the bus
back from eight ash to hate it from
ashbury right to the uh whatever the
[ __ ] i just told you the tenderloin the
tenderloin i'm gonna have to walk two or
three blocks i saw [ __ ] at night that
was just i saw a pimp beating the [ __ ] i
caught the tail end of the chick on the
floor by the bus station and the
tenderloin
so that was all and [ __ ] plus i saw
the the guy that was a boogalong hit the
gay guys and smacked their wig off i saw
a lot of crazy [ __ ] so i'm happy that
you stayed in a nice hotel and you had
no problem oh [ __ ] you know it was
great everyone used to have that show
about the hookers didn't they have a
documentary years ago on hbo about
hookers yeah they've had a bunch of them
i love those in san francisco yeah it's
it's crazy up there the chinese mob is
up there really yeah that's all chinese
run do you
i don't know if it's like i'm
this
the smallest person like i'm not a tough
guy at all but i've always been
maybe i'm stupid i don't really get
scared in cities like i make i make good
choices i don't i don't really go like
i've never walked through i'm gonna go
buy crack in the neighborhood at three
in the morning but like if i was walking
like our hotel was right next to the
tenderloin and we saw some
people who were like man we probably
wouldn't want to hang out with them but
if i was just walking minding my
business like they're not going to me i
don't i've never felt like scared that
they would mess with me if i don't if
i'm not being nosy if i'm not like
trying to like mess with them if i just
walk by i don't think anyone's gonna
mess with you i tell you it's all in
your body language sometimes yeah body
language really tells a lot of you it
tells the energy that you're giving off
um
sometimes if you walk some people walk
and they antagonize people because
they're flexing their arms oh yeah you
know sometimes you know it's just body
language is so much
i used to go into deep neighborhoods
late at night and i'd be scared shitless
but i knew if i contained my body
and i kept eye contact to eliminate and
i walked like i had done it a thousand
times before yeah
nobody would [ __ ] with me you know
atlanta was great too i had a great time
was it really yeah it's a nice little
[ __ ] club man it's very quaint the
people were very nice a nice little
family a nice couple came and gave me a
candle from the chattanooga candle
company a coconut [ __ ] cream
pie
smells delicious you haven't been to
atlanta since i've known you i don't
think well other than rogan's special
right the tabernacle they have
the skull bones which is 73 seats
so if i had 200 people there on thursday
i'd have to do three shows on a [ __ ]
uh
thursday night is it an earthquake or
someone below us doing something i don't
know
so it was the improv was like a year old
it's a great little club nice little
sushi on the menu really
the only knock i had was that they put
me at a hotel where all there was was a
palm and room service
and the california [ __ ] cheesecake
factory across the street so every time
i go to california cheesecake factor is
a 45-minute wait even to set the [ __ ]
bar yeah so i either had a room service
or uh the palms which you know it's not
[ __ ] bad but it's not what i usually
want to [ __ ] spend for lunch and
dinner right it's expensive yeah it's
[ __ ] expensive so weird you
tweeted a picture of original joe's and
it's funny how
i said to you to go and you got to talk
her into it so funny how
every time we go to san jose you've been
with me how many times were we at
original joe's basically every meal we
went we went for breakfast once it
wasn't even breakfast but we woke up and
we like you're like it opens at 10 30 or
whatever it opened and we were there as
we opened the doors take eggs with toast
and they put the steak on the toes or
the butt i don't think we even got hangs
i think we got spaghetti we got
spaghetti but it's
uh
it's one when we talk about food on the
show or restaurants i want people to
know this so they know what i'm talking
about
you know man if you go to that luger
place peter luker in new york that's a
great state okay there's a bunch of
places you'd go for a great steak and
i'll tell you what on the way out it's
gonna cost you 55 i don't know about you
guys i can't pay 55 for a steak that's a
once in a [ __ ] lifetime thing for me
we go we get the mashed potatoes and you
know we go to the lunch special at ruth
chris and get the mutt thing the [ __ ]
eight ounce steak or something when i
talk about great stuff and i know people
listen to the podcast don't have the
money to go to these [ __ ] restaurants
no but original joe's is one of those
places
that i could get a steak in there for 21
and it's [ __ ] delicious with the
onions and the mushrooms and the the
side of pasta you know it's i love that
place to to me i don't i don't like
going to a place where i don't belong
like there's places where i don't belong
man right they got 19 [ __ ] forks
i just need one [ __ ] fork you
know what i'm saying i don't need 19
[ __ ] forks on my salad and for the
that toufee and [ __ ] i'm not eating
bread no more really no i stopped you
cut out all bread good for you that's
hard i got the wheat pasta and the wheat
pasta i don't know the difference
between that and the pasta except the
[ __ ] carbs are the same so what's the
[ __ ] difference but i guess the i
think it's a lie i could i thought that
when i first started looking you think
something like whole wheat is gonna be
better for you and then it's not
i feel like i feel like just eating the
pasta isn't good for you because the
gluten and you get puffy and whatnot but
i was looking at that last night i had
pasta whole wheat pasta cup and i'm
still [ __ ] dying here carb wise well
this this weekend proved it to me is
that it's all about working out because
we stopped and got we wanted this
already stopped this place called casa
de fruta with a whole bunch of candy we
got mcdonald's ones
and i lost weight in san francisco we
walked everywhere
so that's all it is that i feel like
that i mean you have to keep your diet
under control
but if i can lose weight eating candy
and mcdonald's and you just walking up
and down hills
that's all really because you you work
out a lot you work out almost every day
it seems like well
i try to do something every day yeah you
know a little something every day
tomorrow i walk mercy then i'm gonna
take my wife to breakfast and we're
gonna go do doing doug with movies or hi
whatever the [ __ ] it is
then i'll come back and i'll try to
deadlift or something i'll go to jiu
jitsu wednesday
by thursday i'll take a day off maybe
friday do upper and lift okay i always
try to do something this weekend i did
some great stuff i got on the bicycle
for 20 minutes then i jumped on the
elliptical for 30 and then i jumped in
the pool for 20. and i got to tell you i
was [ __ ] sore sunday when i flew
sunday from atlanta yeah i couldn't even
[ __ ] move do you know i slept three
hours on the flight oh good for you
you know that that that my sleeping ever
since i went to jiu jitsu and learned to
breathe on my back and not
uh not panic i'm sleeping now brother so
it's not it's not like you're losing
weight and it's just lessening the sleep
apnea you feel like that too i think
that
but i'm also not having that fear i had
a big time fear of being on my back
anybody who's that who has sleep apnea
and the numbers are high you develop a
fear because you wake up choking
and there's nothing worse than waking up
so i understand waking up choking is
scary but like how does that translate
to jiu-jitsu when you're awake okay
because after you go through that and
after you get it treated okay you still
have the lingering effects of of the
of the going on your back okay and every
once in a while when you go for air
let's say you go to move and you put
your shoulder on the hose or something
and the air locks up and you miss air
you go into that panic state oh [ __ ] and
that's what was happening to me i went
to see the psychotherapist and she get
but it was nothing about that it was
just getting on my back and overcoming
the fear remember when hegan was here he
told the story about getting on the guy
and the guy said get off me i'm
panicking he goes no
breathe stop what you're doing and think
about this and get me off you
if you don't panic and you capture your
breathing again and your mind clears
because breathing keeps your mind really
keeps your mind very clear no matter
what's happening to you if you keep
breathing in and out your nose
and at least you know where you are you
know
it clears your mind it it makes you
block or run or see an opening or he
left his leg opening or he'll drop this
knife on the floor i could stab him in
the cath that you know breathing just
keep breathing you know even in jiu
jitsu when you go like a big thing like
he goes for you you go fam you stop
now you stop you're breathing you're
collecting your thoughts you're looking
at him now you're looking at his right
arm but you know you're going for the
left arm right you know so it's just
little things breathing controls all
that
breathing is everything breathing
controls the lifting when you lift
weights if you do certain exercises a
certain way if your breathing is aligned
with your body you're an unstoppable
force i was never taught to breathe
until five years ago
i was doing everything and holding my
breath okay got it okay so the weights
come on me
instead of
breathing so as they go down you
exhale and as you go up you either
inhale exhale i don't know which ones
i'm just saying once i'm on there so
boom
boom
and you know so it's all with your
breath your breath controls a lot of
movements right yeah when people are
boxing they throw a punch
they throw those little things out you
know whatever the [ __ ] they don't
and then they retract with their nose
then they spit out through their mouth
but in in every aspect breathing is like
when i go swimming i have to change my
breathing
because as i'm going if i'm pushing i'm
sucking in okay as i'm putting my head
up i'm sucking in oxygen once my head
goes down again i'm blowing it out in
the water so when you see somebody
swimming when they turn their head
they're breathing right yeah and as they
go back and they're exhaling breathing
and then they get into a beat so for
every two things they do with their arms
they might pop their head up to the side
but they don't pop it to flex their
muscles it's all part of this motion
boom
boom
boom
boom so it's all part of emotion when
you see a really good swimmer when you
see guys like you and me sweet we go for
air when you see a really good swimmer
breathe it goes through the motion
through his arms he just pops it right
there that motion he's inhaled and as he
hits into the water you see bubbles
coming out right all of a sudden i'm
[ __ ]
uh spongebob squarepants
is that what happened to you at the
store do you think he's like you hold he
hold your breath for too long no i just
walked up the stairs and wasn't thinking
and just
had negative thoughts in my mind and
they escalated to something else with
the reefer you know when i go for a a
blood test
if i don't feel that needle everything's
cool once i feel the needle it sends a
message to my brain and my brain decides
to do something with that message either
i control it
or i let it grow out if i breathe
normally and listen to the music and
dance while i'm getting the blood taken
out everything's [ __ ] primo yeah but
if i tense up from that thing once i
tense up my breath now i'm catching my
breath
and now i'm thinking oh my god i'm gonna
faint oh my god i'm gonna faint and i'm
gonna [ __ ] faint because you're
telling yourself you're gonna [ __ ]
paint right that's what happens to me
i have an issue when i get high around
paula cause she she doesn't do it that
often now anymore
she doesn't want to do it no more she
just can't because she has the the d.a
like she can do it maybe sometimes but
almost never um but if i if i see her i
start to giggle sometimes and i was
wondering do you ever get giggly on me
like you ever sit at home all the time
monday when we ate the 500 milligrams i
kept going home and thinking about
calling you telling you
hey did you ever hear from that dave
t-shirt guy nope all right we're going
to put the [ __ ] pressure on him on
wednesday oh that was so terrible
because i was high out of my mind and i
don't like confrontation and he was
getting all these calls and pizzas sent
to him and i was like he's going to call
the police we're going to go to jail for
work
harassment he can't do dick i was like
he can't do it
joey you forget about this [ __ ]
don't make me start the [ __ ] regime
at 801 again tomorrow because that's
what we'll do
we [ __ ] his world up he was getting
pizzas he got everything [ __ ] him dawg
he was a scumbag to us he was just a
jerker he wasn't even polite
he was he was just playing on [ __ ]
rude
you tried to be nice i tried to be nice
and what do you want me to do what the
[ __ ] i want you to do make good on this
shirt well you can't do that then what
are you talking about then why do
business with you right yeah and we're
gonna [ __ ] up your yelp
so when all these [ __ ] uber drivers
call you to get a t-shirt they know
you're a [ __ ] sack of [ __ ]
we should just call him right now on the
[ __ ] on the podcast and tell him what
we [ __ ] think you want to do it [ __ ]
yeah tell this [ __ ] what's
cracking and [ __ ] we'll send the [ __ ]
cow i feel like going down there with
the cops that's what we should do
now leave them alone because i want to
talk about drug rips today we got okay
we got my main man joey fullado toast
you know when i told that story that day
on how i would set up a drug rip i got
so many [ __ ] emails really
oh my god it was like people's mind were
blown like they had never heard they
never watched the tv show before
nothing like that it's so it's it's
crazy how
for you it's it's totally normal and
it's it's
but for people like me and i think a lot
of the listeners it's just like
at most the most we ever did is buy weed
from some kid at the high school and i
never even did that and you're talking
about casing places and just like wow oh
my god yeah
you know when you write the stories out
that's when i really realized
how [ __ ] crazy i was and how crazy
the situation was
you know when ari was telling me to get
stories ready i wrote a
story about robert a drug dealer before
i went to colorado the first time
and just writing it on paper almost gave
me a nervous breakdown what was it about
it was just a guy that my mother knew
and
they would come up from miami in those
days and get hotels in union city and
you get two or three hotel rooms and
that's how you sell the coke and you
know you go to the room and then they
take the money and they go on they call
somebody and you know and you would call
from room to room to room
uh okay
so you gotta put somebody with
binoculars to watch
and see what room they came out of
jesus and then you got to put cars there
and
anytime they moved out of that room
that's when you want to attack because
when you when you have coke in the hotel
you can't let maids in the room right so
you always have to have somebody in
there switching ships you know would you
ever look at an informant like a maid
and you'd be like tell me when this is i
[ __ ] wish i had that i never you
never had that no
like an inside mate and they have them i
know for a fact that you're made to say
but then again the maids get in trouble
somebody gets robbed
like in boulder a a guy had a [ __ ]
truck filled with weed one time
and i guess he took eight of the pounds
and put him under his bed and the maid
found him
called the cops on the guy that was
really popular in boulder when i went to
jail in boulder county like when they
were holding me right
10 20 of the people were in there were
because of hotel mistakes jesus just
people going to a hotel the cops come to
the hotel at night and do a background
check on all the guests really
it's some weird [ __ ] i've heard some
weirdest [ __ ] why not yeah [ __ ] it you
know uh and and they've done stupid [ __ ]
they've done stupid [ __ ] like that
you know i've heard maids come back and
smell weed i think i don't smoke in my
[ __ ] hotel rooms i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm not smoking in my [ __ ] hotel i
don't care people do it all the time
it's like robbing a car once they come
in you're guilty i smell the pot in your
room right that gives them the right to
save my room what if i'm in atlanta
there's no [ __ ] legal weed there
right yeah any of these there's no legal
weed i smoke a joint i go for a [ __ ]
walk man
and nobody gets their feelings hurt you
know but you never know you give them
you know i i heard of people with 20
pounds of coke in their trunk smoking a
joint in that car
jesus you get pulled over you smell the
weed i'm going to open up your [ __ ]
trunk
you know all these little things that
cops look for anybody looks for
these are just basic minor league
mistakes do you have comment more common
sense or did you make these mistakes
i watch people to make those mistakes
you force people to make those mistakes
you force them into something they won't
do okay i watched that movie focus on
the plane i watched two movies on the
plane on the way to atlanta the first
one was that sean penn going to beirut
or something horrid
him and the guy that won the oscar for
the one who's married to the chick i
don't [ __ ] know from that movie with
how the [ __ ] i'm not sure the spanish
dude who's the antonio banderas no the
other dude that came after him that was
in
i was married to penelope cruz
oh i'll look it up that [ __ ] dude
real real good looking dude so sean penn
does a movie with him that movie was a
[ __ ] sleeping pill but then there was
a movie called focus or something
with uh the fresh prince of bel-air and
some hot little blonde chick
okay and the movie's all about scamming
people
about javier burnham uh javier bardem
how to scam people and they the main
scam is
this chinese guy that's a professional
gambler and they scan them at the super
bowl because him and her are betting
numbers on the jersey or who scores
first what's he going to do next
and they pull the scam okay where the
guy goes i want to bet with you guys
they gamble loud enough to suck the guy
in
and they just keep betting bet and
betting they get up to like four million
dollars and will smith is going to lose
and the chick doesn't want him to lose
because it's money they scammed from all
these it's when
a big event happens in a town right how
a team of people come into that town to
pickpocket
you know that's why i hate those big
events the suckers paradise that's when
maids give information
that's when maids are like [ __ ] you
joey diaz and this [ __ ] other guy in
this room i could smell the [ __ ] coke
in there you know i'm not stupid i smell
i see the alcohol yeah i see the [ __ ]
residue on the [ __ ] glass tables
so
this is what happens when there's a
super bowl uh indy 500 a big event comes
to your town oh not only does your town
get infested with hookers but your town
gets infested with small time crooks
like i was really like there's like
traveling crooks traveling crooks no way
and all they do is run games they
[ __ ] pickpocket you they you know and
this these people were very high tech
they would pickpocket you
you know use the cards take the cash and
then
buy products with those cards and put
them on ebay that's brilliant
that is [ __ ] brilliant that's why you
get great deals on ebay
oh that's smart as [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
smart as [ __ ]
people got a brand new computer for 300
that caught remember i told you i'd go
to the house and say what do you want i
want a 500 computer i'm going to be back
back here now i want 250 cash i'm not
sure
i can't prove it but i think there's
someone in a post office around here
with this card scanner because twice
from bank of america i've got a credit
card and before i've even activated it i
get a call are you spending 500 at
macy's this much here
and it's just it's this little
everything people doing it this area
here you're crazy to put your card in
anything
in anything yeah jesus whether it's this
is this is russianville
this is russianville this is this is up
here you go to glendale your card's
gonna get stolen you go to las vegas
your card's gonna get stolen you know uh
there's people you know they put like
that guy in that movie in that that
[ __ ] thing they showed him taking a
whole atm machine out of the wall that
was fake
no way
i worked in retail for like five or six
years including restaurants and stores
and i never really saw any of that so
those waitresses when they come to you
and they say you want a drink yeah let
me run a tab there's a there's a guy
sitting there with one of those machines
and she goes up to him with the card he
takes the card swipes and when she walks
back he puts your card on the table so
they already got your [ __ ] numbers
that's when the waitresses are in on it
hell yeah but they got everything on
camera you see in las vegas so once you
call that in
if a bunch of them appear they're gonna
look through the [ __ ] film and those
people who are looking for gambling
people they see those type of scams too
so it's a
it's tough to be a [ __ ] criminal
today
it's got to be i'm pleased because
everybody's got a camera look at what
happens and whatever with that pot store
they had visible cameras
the pot store they broke into and the
cops were eating the brownies oh yeah
where the [ __ ] cop department's still
saying that those guys weren't eating
brownies but they're on tape eating
brownies and there's more tapes jesus
that's what they don't know there's more
tapes in the back when they were robbing
their [ __ ] pockets
that people had cameras on the saves
cameras on the floor safe they had
cameras everywhere there's even more
cameras so yeah people i listen if i if
i had [ __ ] money in my house
200 000 and a half a kilo in my house
i'd have cameras that you'd see
and i'd have cameras that you wouldn't
see that'd be the smart thing yeah you
have to let them take down the cameras
and giggle we got this and you still got
two more [ __ ] cameras pointing at
your loot pointed at your door
microphone microphone everything if you
have the money you can have everything
now you can watch your house while
you're out of the house can you not
there's a red band red band has
something that they sell for like a
hundred bucks now like uh a web nanny
camera even now they have like actual
security cameras they can do it but it's
uh
yeah it's crazy do you think now if you
like if you were to be born when i was
born let's say and how many cameras and
computers they have now do you think you
still would have been a criminal or do
you think something else would happen no
because everything you do they got you
on a [ __ ] tape i mean you live
in a on a [ __ ] tape right whether i'm
at the airport whether i get out of a
cab you know when you go to the airport
and you park your car you don't think
you're being watched
i know you should park your car why
wouldn't you i don't think i think i
just don't think about it i know if
you're if you're the nsa if you're who's
ever watching airports
i'm taking a bomb out of my [ __ ]
trunk and put it in my luggage or
whatever the [ __ ] i'm gonna do i'm
watching that parking lot yeah i'm
watching a mile outside the parking lot
as soon as i make that right
onto century boulevard okay i got a
camera right there if i'm the nsa the
camera is everywhere though that could
be a [ __ ] truck i just want to
scratch my balls and my balls were
hanging out because i ripped my pants
all the way down the middle today was i
don't have a wardrobe day today as i was
leaving i went to pour the iced tea and
mercy put the lid on and then tighten it
so it went all over my shirt and then i
got in the car and my something got
cooked
hooked on the door hinge and i ripped my
pants right across the middle but you
know me i didn't give a [ __ ] i went to
the bank i took out 50 bucks i went to
the weed store with my dick out nobody
called no underwear no but no underwear
what would that work it's 88 degrees
does mercy laugh when you make mistakes
like that when you spill juice in your
shower she didn't see it she was in the
other room and nobody saw it just me
like an [ __ ]
i used to love i used to my i had a
problem when i was young if i was
uncomfortable with something like if
something was made me feel awkward i
would laugh so if someone fell i would
laugh
so i didn't i didn't know if mercy
that's why i laugh at you when you're
[ __ ] all stone drooling like a mobile
over here
so i'm gonna have joey fulato call up i
haven't had him in a while it's nice
when we have people call up to break up
the monotony wednesday is our 300th
[ __ ] episode that's crazy
300 [ __ ] episodes of a podcast who
the hell does this craziness rogan's got
600 doesn't he yeah at least 669 or some
[ __ ] like yeah that's what you were yeah
six [ __ ] hundred episodes i thought
about afterwards 600 [ __ ] episodes
what is adam corolla up to he must be up
to like thousands thousands marc maron
thousands yeah it's uh it's amazing
i i someone said something i think it
was i think it was leon and twitter said
like the original churches were were
great but chaotic and i haven't even
listened to them but like they must have
been
remember when we we used to do football
picks and they were all always wrong
every pick we ever had was the loser we
just gave up on it well when i started
the podcast i wanted to have people on
that i had
grown up with just to show the state of
mind that i grew up in so people knew
where the [ __ ] i was coming from right i
thought it would simplify matters i
thought people listen and go this isn't
for me or this is for me and we had some
wild times on that podcast we had some
wild times in the [ __ ] apartment
but if you listen to the podcast you can
see how much you've grown we've grown as
people we've grown as human beings even
the people that come up to me now and go
i've been asking is beauty and the beast
wow you wouldn't still be here if you
didn't hear something
so i appreciate that you're still
[ __ ] listening after 300 goddamn
episodes i mean who else talks about
drug reps and i want to talk about this
[ __ ] you know that day when we were
talking about it my heart was beating
really oh just thinking about uh what
it's like to get up in the morning have
no money in the bank
a bank account was the farthest thing
from my mind
if i didn't have it in my pocket in
those days i didn't have it lee
i would say to myself i'm gonna open my
account i'm gonna be in there two days
later taking the money out there was no
savings in my life back then
you lived by a hustling you know and
that's what you wanted you wanted to
bump into somebody i said come here
i'm selling some coke now nobody the
cocaine business in the early 80s mid
80s is like the podcasting business now
nobody really knows
nobody knows what's gonna happen every
day this [ __ ] changes now you got
periscope so when people people that
sold coke didn't just start selling coke
they sold weed before the cocaine okay
and they figure why am i selling two
pounds of weed and i could sell an ounce
of coke and make the same [ __ ] dough
red meat
you follow me instead of selling this
much i'm gonna sell this much
so they had an idea but also nobody
breaks into your house for a pound of
wheat
people will break into your house for an
ounce of coke
people will set you up in weird ways for
four ounces of coke
you know the way the cops send you know
for a cup to
somebody's phone
for a cop to really get you they have to
make multiple buys or two ounces or more
okay all right two ounces is a standard
they're not gonna bust you the first two
ounces well isn't that a lot because
this don't you didn't you usually buy it
by grams so if it's two hours that seems
like a lot to buy
but how the cops set you up okay is they
buy a gram a gram an eight ball
two ounces
oh okay they come to you and they say
the coke you have is tremendous now i
want to buy two ounces once they go for
that 56 grand
that's how they [ __ ] get you to roll
okay you know anybody could do a [ __ ]
year for a gram of blow
you know it's distribution you were
distributing you look at this [ __ ]
guy he got a dui what'd he do a week
later
he went into a rehab that's what you do
when you get he took a week
he took a week too long
so when you get busted for selling the
grandma copeland it's your first defense
you could beat this with a good
background and if you do some work what
do i mean by beat it
you could do 60 days into rehab and
three years probation they're going to
test you but you're not going to go to
jail right that's beating that's okay
you know if you sold cops aren't going
to get you for a grant because they
don't a year you could do it standing on
your head
they're going to scare you and say you
should roll you don't [ __ ] roll for a
grand they're gonna get you to roll for
two ounces that's when you do six or
seven years have you listened to the
[ __ ] the podcast serial no
i don't i won't
spoil it for anyone but it's it's about
a guy who was convicted of murder and
they're saying might not have done it
and one of the things that is talked
about in the case is that the main
witness
was coached might have been coached by
the police
or like threatened like we'll charge you
with this unless you see what we want do
you ever have any dealings like that
like where they were like
no but if somebody if a cop wants to
make a conviction
bad enough they'll do dumb [ __ ]
yeah you know what happened with
hurricane carter
the boxer
and there's been thousands of arrests
where uh
they're wrong arrests you know but if a
cop really wants it
or they're being pressured actually it
too
i believe a lot of [ __ ] and i i don't
believe a lot of this [ __ ] because i've
done time right and you've never been
somebody who's done time that's guilty
nobody's guilty right they all got set
up
it was their uncle's fault
nobody ever is guilty okay but
uh
the cops will [ __ ] you know they
could darken something up man they could
they they have all the power
they have all the [ __ ] power to
darken some up if it really didn't
happen eventually you'll beat it you
know all these guys are getting out of
jail now 20 years later 25 years i mean
you can't get your life back what you
could do is sue them for 20 million get
three and get your dick sucked for the
ten years you do have left in this world
you know if you do 25 [ __ ] years i
can't imagine being in prison wrongly
but i could see it because where there's
smoke there's fire
right
you know listen lee if you walk if
you're here with me
today for two hours okay and a little
jew shoot somebody at subway sandwich on
[ __ ] laurel canyon and ten people say
it's you when i say you're here with me
okay right
what do you think's gonna happen
probably ten against one right i mean
and now they're gonna break my
credibility you know yeah i mean unless
you're on microphone and people watching
you on you stream and you have a
thousand well that's the issue the the
trial was from 99 before they had any of
that [ __ ] now
hopefully it's gonna happen a lot less
but it then it's crazy how that happens
i talked to paul about that because she
wants to be a d.a and she was kind of
freaking out about it like how it's a
lot of pressure to maybe put someone in
who's not
guilty well listen after a few years you
see things for what they are
you know you have a radar and we're all
compassionate at first you're all very
compassionate but once you've been a cop
for five six years once you've been a da
for five six years
and you see the horrible things that
life really has to offer that most
individuals in this life do not see you
here and they probably get cynical yeah
we hear [ __ ] now because it's on the
internet we hear about that lady
lighting her baby on fire in the
microwave oven
you know i mean because it's on the
internet and news is national now 20
years ago you didn't hear all those
things so cops dealt with it on a
[ __ ] local level right you know it
wears on a cop to see that type of
so
once you get jaded or what's the word
you used uh
i think cynical san diego cynical
you think to yourself that everybody's
guilty right
everybody and you do this not just with
that we do this with when we're
uh editors we figure that every [ __ ]
company is robbing us right when we're
comedians we're always on the look for
you know you're always doing all these
things but you're watching your back
right well as a cop i mean anybody who
comes in
there's always a good cop back um
there's always one cup that sucks you
and the other cop saying you're a liar
and you gotta you know you gotta protect
yourself i mean right now god forbid
tonight something happens and uh
something happens that somebody dies
it's close to me
right and i was over there they're gonna
[ __ ] call me in and they're gonna
[ __ ] ring me right me and say you
were there
listen what happened you got into an
argument over a podcast and you hit him
in the head with a [ __ ] thing of uh
uh
alpha brain and you know they paint the
picture and now you got to fight
yourself out and if you say the wrong
thing you're putting the [ __ ] cell my
friend
so if you're putting a [ __ ] cell here
you are wrongly accused or whatever the
[ __ ] you got i mean i can see it i've
been i'm very fortunate i've been scared
half my life because of that right of
being wrongly accused of something you
could be driving we could be leaving the
podcast tonight at six o'clock at night
making a u-turn the cop will pull us
over and say get out of the car we just
saw you at a bank heist over on 66th and
communicable avenue and there you are
right where the [ __ ] you are it's
terrible at all what we got a call oh
that's terrifying though
what's up my brother
what's up coco what's going on my man
how are you doing a long time long time
he's going to be in vegas with us in
september man joey [ __ ] f what's up
baby how's the difference oh yeah is
that lee sciott what's that
yet
it's been a long time since you spoke to
the flying vegas too the flying jupiter
the flying jew always goes to vegas he's
a staple it's like going to vegas in the
50s i'm not seeing dean martin there's
you
and you don't know what he's up to i
can't wait to mine
too he's up to 500 milligrams on edibles
he's shutting [ __ ] down up to
it doesn't really it doesn't really
count if you puke all over your kitchen
he [ __ ] puked the tortellini because
it's wholesale totally immediately i
can't wait to meet you too joey
what's going on bro hey coke you know
what i got i gotta call up i gotta call
up on a landline because i really can't
hear you too good i'm gonna call you
right back on a landline take your time
but hurry up all right all right
bye-bye now being wrongly accused has
always scared the [ __ ] out of me you
could be leaving somewhere at two in the
morning
and somebody sees you a blue shirt
you catch a beating they take you to
[ __ ] and half these people look at
that guy and whatever that they was
wrongly accused he was driving home they
beat the [ __ ] out of them and he got
like three million from the [ __ ] city
of los angeles jesus the real the reason
the city of los angeles is broke is
because they pay out all those lawsuits
what's up joey
not much baby for all those listeners
out there joey
bag of donuts is back oh [ __ ] helping
joe fulato oh [ __ ]
enjoy about six weeks ago about six
weeks ago we were here
and i was talking to somebody and we
started getting into the story about
drug rips how
in the 80s nobody really knew what was
going on and people were pot deers and
and then we came along and it was like
uh
you know i had only done two of them
where we played cops and that type of
[ __ ] everything else i did was sure some
guy who [ __ ] beat us on three
quarters of a gram we got pissed we
broke in his house and robbed him for an
ounce and a half which to us in those
days was a million [ __ ] dollars
sure sure definitely
you know yep
well you know in my career i did a lot
of that [ __ ] uh i did something with a
couple of guys that you probably know
his name is uh big lou okay he's gonna
call in later
oh my god he was he was the man with
that coax i mean all we did is
we had this guy
in new york city we had this black guy
that it was like a patterson cop
and he would go around and he just
[ __ ] sit on like 179th street in
amsterdam and just look for people you
know what i mean and all of a sudden we
get a phone call
it would be me big lou and danny those
are the ones that would do it you know
and uh we did it for a while we had
teams man we had teams big big lou comes
in right ask him about fasco
there was this uh
you know 178th and um saint nicholas
right when you come over you make that
right turn under before the bridge
afterwards right there
after the break right there yep there's
a it's the 34th precinct
and uh we took this guy one time man we
got in the van we drew them in a van we
locked him up we we handcuffed him and
we drove him around for like two hours
trying to beat the [ __ ] out of him
beating him up trying to get his keys to
his house he wouldn't give us the keys
finally
he gave us the keys to his house we go
into his house he got nothing there so
big lou tells them listen and i don't
know if you haven't met big lou bigler
was six foot six
300 pounds he's very very scary
big luke told them say listen man you
know we're not the cops so it's either
you
money or your body what he said the guy
all of a sudden made a phone call we
were standing coax right out on 178
right out in front of the um
the police station he makes a phone call
to this guy now it's me lou
and this guy fosco i got a nine
millimeter in my bed in my pocket and
lou's got a badge on with a shirt over
it and a hat
so now he thinks first he thought we
were cops so all of a sudden this guy
pulls up and also he starts saying
something in spanish something spanish
all of a sudden
vasco gets in the car the other guy gets
out of the car he goes hold on one
second i'll be right back
now we got this guy we're holding him
for ransom
you know so we're talking all of a
sudden 20 minutes later he comes back
with a with a a bag a brown bag with 10
000 in cash and a kilo
and he gives it to us all of a sudden we
let the guy go we jump in one of those
uh gypsy camps and boom we go right over
to the uh right over to his house in
palisade park that was a great score of
us man oh my god there's so many of them
i can tell you about how old how old
were you joey was this like high school
was this like high school or later
well this is a little bit late to lead
this is probably about when i was 20 21
years old you know that that was my that
was our job that was our job you know i
mean and we would just live by school by
score you know i mean we we had one time
we were
we had no money and all of a sudden
danny was like well i can do somebody
out in california who's got a lot of
weed we're like okay let's do it so all
of a sudden we start playing in this
caper and we go to lou's house and we're
figuring out things that lou's father
lou's father was a career criminal too
he's like you guys are [ __ ] cr how
how are you going to get the hardware on
the plane and hardware meeting the guns
and stuff like that so we're like we
don't know
so all of a sudden we go out to
california and we're going to meet
can i say his name jmo i can tell you i
already said it's over you know we meet
him all of a sudden we meet him one day
danny goes meet him we come back the
next day we go to uh like uh uh a gun
store and we get pellet guns coco we get
pellet guns
all of a sudden now we go get two
thousand dollars in cash and we put it
all in singles and we put hundred dollar
bills on the outside so it looks like we
got a lot of money danny calls up
jmo he meets us at the hotel now
danny is setting up jmo
so all of a sudden
he comes into the hotel i'm standing in
the closet you have no events in the
closet you can see out the door
and lose on lose on the um balcony all
of a sudden he comes walking through the
door i jump out with my pellet gun but i
have it up in the eggs i don't want him
to see the front of it because you know
the hole was small all of a sudden i
said freeze you're under arrest all of a
sudden luke came off the balcony grabbed
him threw danny and the other guy on the
floor like oh my god there it is lou i
opened up the bed it was 62 pounds of
weed in one big giant like two bags he
had
we grabbed them we handcuffed them to
the sink we threw the keys there and we
left them both there we just bolted out
of there
some of the [ __ ] we did with lou was
[ __ ] crazy man crazy with that big
guy
oh my god i remember handcuffing a guy
and i was never so scared in my life
joyful
i was pretty excuse me by the time i
handcuffed the guy i went to jail for
kidnapping i wasn't scared but before
that i had handcuffed two guys
and i was [ __ ] my [ __ ] pants off
oh man i mean
we did all we did for like maybe five
years straight we would just you know
live score the score so all of a sudden
you know it would run out all of a
sudden boom we'd wait for a phone call
from this guy al and all of a sudden
every couple of months we would go over
there and take down the drug dealers you
know i know a couple of guys had like
you remember um
he went to jail his name is uh dave uh
forgot his last name yeah uh he went to
jail for killing somebody they they
kidnapped him they stuck staples in his
head they killed him him and uh anthony
um caselli
you know they all had everybody had
their own teams and stuff but thank god
i never got caught
and uh you know luke lu liu did a lot of
them lou had a really big one one time
man he could tell you someone about
unbelievable that's how i met him though
you know doing that kind of stuff
you know he was a professional boxer too
lou we could tell you some of those
stories you know you
you graduated in 85 i graduated in 82
when i was always a year older when my
mother died in haiti my mother had
my mother was in that world they were
coming to the house the first time i did
blow with lubes i stole it from
10 kilos that were in my basement i
didn't even know what they were worth
and i would just take coke and give it
to my friends i didn't know what the
[ __ ] it was yeah but after my mom died i
kept in contact with those people
and these people were serious [ __ ]
cubans and they would come up from miami
call me and say they're in town they
want to see me for me to give them money
and then they'd introduce me to their
friend in union city and like nine out
of ten i robbed that guy and in those
days i was climbing roofs
i was doing the sick as [ __ ] i mean it
was natural for me joey oh it was
natural it was i remember i remember
rego used to tell me all the [ __ ] you
were doing oh my god he was the only guy
i was honest with i mean i was a piece
of [ __ ] but if you if you thought joey
in those days if you [ __ ] with me in
north bergen and there was a lot of
people in those days i thought they were
cute
and i was down and they [ __ ] like you
know i could give you five names of
people i thought they were cute with me
and at the end of the day i [ __ ]
clipped them
and they knew i did it and they couldn't
do a [ __ ] thing about it
and it was so funny and then i realized
i could clip people all around
and i was catching people
sleeping
we did awesome for years i didn't work
for years that's all we did you know
because in new york city jersey it's so
easy you go right across the bridge and
then we had this black guy when you
asked lou about al he was black and he
was a patterson cop so it was actually
so great he used to stand right on the
corner and he could stand with these you
know those the mulligans and the and all
the dominicans and stuff like that over
there you know and he wouldn't even they
wouldn't even know he was there all of a
sudden a couple of days later we get a
phone call all right it's on meet me
over here at 160th and uh st nicholas
all right here we go we're going to work
you know it was crazy at that time
though and then uh and then one time
we uh almost got uh the the fbi [ __ ]
uh called us and uh louie uh got caught
with the fbi and all of a sudden this
and that oh my god it was a big [ __ ]
ordeal i had to go in front of the fbi
one hundred center street jack
campanella his name was oh my god i'll
never forget that
[ __ ] man it was 80.
i must have robbed
200 drug dealers joey and i don't
there's so many that
just did little fuck-ups like when i
went to colorado i took my new jersey
technology mind
i was a new jersey criminal in north
berlin where people see you coming a
mile away
you understand yeah i grew up in a
society in colorado they don't see you
in colorado and new jersey they see they
see this setup they're like why is it
getting exactly why has this kid been
coming over here too much they know he
used to buy grams now he's buying eight
balls where is he getting the money from
people have ears so i went from i went
from [ __ ] new jersey where they saw
you coming with colorado where they
didn't even suspect it and i was
shutting their lights up i was shoveling
snow robbing you know what i was doing
joey i knew drug dealers had coconut
house let's say i go in and have four
ounces i take two like two eight balls
and i kept them on a string and then i
kept them on a string i had a and then
what i would do is when i get ready to
rob them i wait till they get a big ship
and then i [ __ ] take them down
but for a month i'd take them for an
eight ball a day like nothing they'd be
skiing what are the [ __ ] good money
back there that'd be good yeah but this
is what i tell people i was talking
about periscope this morning with this
[ __ ] comic con you know we got
[ __ ] isis cutting people's heads off
and you're in san diego dressed up like
batman like a jerk off ghost you know
what i'm saying like a [ __ ] jerk off
that you all have these [ __ ] momos ah
star trek look at me like a [ __ ]
meanwhile those are the people i pray on
those [ __ ] jerk calls because they're
too busy listen drug dealers don't do
that you know what drug dealers do they
sell drugs they don't watch tv
they're the best people that rob they
can't go to the cops
when a drug dealer would not when a drug
dealer would tell me he was going to
disneyland or going skiing
and i'd ask him how many times again do
you ski i ski every week on wednesdays
bingo
this [ __ ] is going down
eventually
on wednesday
and they tell you i don't scream on
wednesday we party out really even as a
criminal you didn't take vacations
criminals don't have you never listen if
i went on a vacation i robbed people
listen san francisco i caused so much
havoc in a hotel in san francisco
because i used to steal it i used to rob
the maid's keys the maids in those days
would leave the keys in the door and
they cleaned so i'd watch them yeah and
i'd take the [ __ ] key and it was over
after that i had two or three there was
a bookmaker i robbed in san francisco in
the hotel he couldn't figure out who was
robbing me come to me and go somebody
keeps [ __ ] robbing me he was one of
those dollar guys that sold those
tickets yeah yeah he got three miles i'd
take all every [ __ ] single plus all
the slips from him and [ __ ] his world up
he'd be sitting in the lobby going
somebody [ __ ] robbed me again in the
building that [ __ ] [ __ ] made and it
was me the whole time i beat the [ __ ]
burrito yeah
oh my god oh my god i i could see a drug
dealer a mile away
oh yeah yeah well that's how it was over
by us you know everybody had their own
teams and we were doing it from like
maybe 88 to 92
easy every [ __ ] week doing it danny
knows a lot too thank you it was me
danny and louis that was the team and
then we had this guy al you guys got so
good you started robbing each other
you [ __ ] started robbing each
other you took you made russo and kurt
go down to florida these guys started
robbing each other one of the greatest
quotes i ever heard in my life was july
or something of 99 i took darren to
breakfast in the middle of his food
i looked at him like oh you still get
into fights he goes there's nobody left
to fight i gotta fight my friends now
i got nobody left to fight i gotta fight
my friends that's how i got with these
guys they had nobody left to rob so they
started robbing each other so it was
these two clicks in north bergen first
they started together rousseau and and
and and and this danny bianco they were
the [ __ ] hottest drug team since
[ __ ] aberdeen costello they were
buying trucks
you think i'm kidding you they were
moving they were like they were like
cracking in tubs
every time i went back to bring them
guns they had [ __ ]
trucks and ski jeeps what are those
things you ski with
these guys were making big money then
one time i heard that broken up
tommy tried to rob the other guy then
they went out war for each other then
they even got they couldn't get coke one
went to miami who they robbed they rob
kurt
curtin miami right they robbed curtin
miami they went all the way down and
they get robbed who said to me look at
danny danny we robbed his cousin we
robbed his cousin jmo it was [ __ ]
like 60 something pounds of weed we had
to take and then we then was funny we
got it and then also we had to drive it
all the way down the laws because we
were someplace in
in diamond bar california also we had to
drive up to los angeles then we had to
ship it back in the mail and we shipped
it to some place in patterson oh my god
it was but jama was calling danny for
months for months because he knew he set
him up he set him up and that was it but
he had a rob we were so down and out we
had to rob his cousin
told me how to do
oh man but it was that was the time
thank god i'm i'm on the land though now
now i'm hiding out thank you nobody
knows where i am listen man every every
month i get a nervous breakdown i do a
podcast with lee i gotta tell you joey i
do a podcast with lee and i eat an
edible
and for some reason i go home and i
smoke some pot and i make some coffee
and my [ __ ] mind starts to race
at 11 30.
i can't lie to you sometimes i get tears
in my eyes and i say i can't believe i
survived that situation or going to
westwood oh my god west new york one
night wait wait till we tell which i see
lee the situation lee that we lived in
man it's like it's you guys live in
disney world compared to it it sounds
like north bergen was like an indian
burial ground or something like that i
remember one day
all you guys they black sister was
[ __ ] a colombian drug dealer the hot
one she was just giving them [ __ ] for
coke
giving them and dave knew it yeah it's
like my sister's just basically giving
him [ __ ] for coke she's hot and she
knows it she just goes with a gizmo
[ __ ] he throws like an ounce of blood
once a week and we went over there and
robbed him while he was [ __ ] the
sister
that's how cold
we were
and the whole thing wow and the sister
was on all fours sucking his dick i mean
it was horrible we're robbing the guy
and she's sucking this i mean you can't
write this [ __ ] really save some for her
no
no you cannot write this no way and he
got caught
out the window so the drug dealer had
him by the hair thank god whoever the
[ __ ] was driving kept the car running i
mean it was just this is [ __ ] that i sit
there sometimes that's a way of life
over by us you know that was it i mean
you go right into manhattan i mean go to
washington heights and rob somebody and
just get out of there we do it on a
friday night all of a sudden boom you
need some money go make a score come
back and what the quintessence the one i
did the one i did in 93 was with your
cousin god bless his soul
did you guys rob the gas station with
the water guns we robbed the gas station
with the water guns we never had to pull
them what and then we robbed we robbed
all the stereos from sears
the car stereos every [ __ ] blob punk
did you put the one in on
senior prom you robbed the alpine you
put it in russo's car before that i
never forget it you came out of the
[ __ ] what was it i think two guys
down there or kmart you had the alpine
in the box with the speakers and
everything you took around
we need cash how are we going to make
some cash let's go get some car stereo
brand new in a box and we walk in a
store like a team and each of us should
get one so that's three 200 stereos
we're gonna get 300 that's an eight ball
that's 250 and ten dollars a piece how
did you get them and back in 1982 it was
a lot of money that was a lot of money
was 250 135th in amsterdam our goal was
to go over every day for an eight ball
so you had to come up with 250. 250
quick quickly some days i get a call
from somebody going dawg you got a
toolkit for sale i heard can you get me
the one that sees it but
how did you turn the stereos into money
you already it's a car stereo lee i come
to your house and i go lee not for
nothing i sat in your volkswagen the
other day and the stereo sounded like
[ __ ] i got a blob punk for sale it's 300
new
give me 150 cash
and you'd say [ __ ] yeah for 300 all
those speakers we used to get the speed
that's how you got your day started
right right right so what speakers yeah
so now that 250 for the eight ball that
was an investment you took that 250 you
threw a gram on that now you sold three
of those and you got 300 plus you got a
half grand for me and joey and we ran
from there and then there was some guy
who wanted an eight ball so now we take
an eight ball take a gram and a half out
throw a gram and a half a cut in that
[ __ ] and give that to him we
just made a gram and a half a pure now
we got a gram and a half of pure we're
gonna throw another half on and get 200
out of so you know what in a day we each
ended up with 150 cash and we got the
snort and eight ball that was your game
yeah that was armand and regal loved
that regal loved doing that [ __ ] man i
loved it he loved it i remember one time
me and him robbed this [ __ ] dude that
was a [ __ ] and he thought he was cute
when we went to his house and he had
checks and in those days our boy dick
williams was at the [ __ ] bank and i
used to steal the checks and bring him
right to the bam
they could have jesus christ on a crutch
on those [ __ ]
down there [ __ ] you the car lot the bank
i remember when the dude from joe
marries used to write checks the loan
shark and we take him to the [ __ ]
bank on 70th street while the check's
getting cash your next door gilberto is
getting a cuban sandwich and a badito de
mame are you [ __ ] getting me a what
dog your whole day surrounded around
making money for food but the payoff was
drugs and we keep investing the money
so every time you went every time you
went to the city you went with somebody
else's money how much how much worth
like how much were the drugs worth that
you snorted throughout the day because
like 150
to go to jail that many times isn't
doesn't seem worth it what do you mean
we're not going with yeah that's what
i'm saying going to jail it was just the
excitement of job robbing the 150 in the
eight ball
i remember one of your cousin one night
i had gone to buy drugs downtown in
north bergen some guy set up he was a
cowboy
right next to by kathy moran do you know
that block we were just talking about
mike that you lived
some white kid some white i remember
kathy moran some white kids started
selling coke
and i remember that i went down there
tuesday with somebody and bought the
coke and on the way out i said that's
interesting that window
i could climb in that [ __ ] window
and
as i was talking to the guy he was
telling me that he had a day job he gets
home at five this is the best coke he
was getting it from cubans this is 1981
joey i'll never forget what a mistake
that was done had a day job and i was in
a bar with your cousin on thursday night
just talking to darren he had the ice
box and just on the cube yeah yeah the
icebox remember that icebox i said do me
a favor pick me up at nine we're gonna
rob this
i was lying to him guys i swear to my
mother i was lying to him i had nowhere
to rob i was just getting him to pick me
up because we were gonna rob somebody
and i'm gonna forget i was sleeping on
ronnie's floor
in those days i used to sleep on
ronnie's floor
they were my adopted family and he
knocked on the glass
go go get up let's go make some money
and i went upstairs brushed my teeth
washed my face took a quick shower ran
outside and
this guy's
staying that's how we lived fully it was
a friday morning it was crazy all week
was [ __ ] monday through thursday was
[ __ ] i could always borrow a 20 from
lee and a 20 from joey i could always
put it together but friday it was d-day
everybody wants that money plus you got
to have your money you want to get your
dick sucked you want to do blow you want
to eat quaaludes you got to pay
attention
back then everybody was doing this [ __ ]
so what did i do i tell you i tell your
cousin let's go down to this guy we went
down by giving that terrorist where i
grew up i parked and i basically walked
like i it's like i i never forgot like i
get goosebumps
and i wow my god [ __ ] right right he's
thinking about it i rang his doorbell
like i may believe like i didn't know
that he was working nobody answered
i went around i opened that window like
i told you guys it was wide open
it was the window into it because in
those days you had a door that went to
your doorway that your door was open i
climbed yeah yeah he left this door open
a [ __ ] drug deal
and i ran in
i opened up
there was nothing nothing i wanted a
room where he gave we walked out and
sure enough there's a bag of blowing
that had been cut and one that had been
uncut i took it and on the way out i saw
you know those german flasks
yeah for all mike the beer the big flats
yeah oh yeah the the big giant flask of
steins you know at those days i was a
thief guys
i was a jeff so a thief knows where
people hide [ __ ] and for some reason
yeah
all he had was blow at the house i
wanted his drawers all he had was blow
and as i'm walking out something made me
catch that german thing with the thing
that you pop and it goes back yeah
yeah yeah it's a stein it's called the
stein i think i went over to it i took
that thing up
and there was eight hundred dollar bills
not just like right now everybody's at
home going joey eight hundred dollars
you're a [ __ ] petty thief yes i was
but 800 in 1982
was that that was like 100 that was huge
i remember giving you a [ __ ]
400 he was crying like in those days
darren's mother had gotten divorced
darren didn't have a dad you know darren
lived with john and his mother didn't
have any money yeah yep for darren to
have ten dollars was a lot i gave him
400
and i gave him half of that bag of blow
we [ __ ] went out but that was how it
was it was all a hunch lee
like by 12 o'clock
we had blow we had everything set for
the weekend and it got from that that
now we wanted more everybody wanted the
kilo guy everybody wanted to break into
somebody's house
everybody wanted the big score [ __ ]
jewelry you know i only i got a couple
of with louie but louie got a couple of
big ones without me he got a he got a
couple of 10 kilo ones one time louie
let him tell a story about the asking
about the story about the him and al
were following a guy and all of a sudden
the guy made a wrong turn and went up
onto the bridge
all of a sudden they were behind him the
guy got nervous he jumped out of the car
left it running on the bridge louie
jumped in the car and went back went
into new jersey he went back in the
trunk there was 10 kilos in the trunk
coke 10 kilos ask him about it well the
sanctuary
when the guy pulled on the west side
jumped out
he jumped out and [ __ ] he was so
nervous because they were in this guy al
used to have like a an impala like a
squaring power look at a cop car with a
light on it
and all of a sudden they were following
him the guy made a wrong turn went up on
the bridge put it in the park and jumped
over the [ __ ] railing and jumped and
went up to the like that henry hunter
parkway
and took off and lou we got into the car
jumped in went right into palisade park
got 10 keys if i was sick i wasn't there
that day i was sick but one time i got
the big score in 93 that's where the guy
pulled over he didn't pull up on the
bridge he pulled over on headset henry
hudson highway going downtown
yeah he's going downtown
we stopped him no he stopped himself
like by 135 and we noticed him we went
and made a u-turn and he was out of the
[ __ ] car already he was out of the
car those days they were trained to run
you know i didn't go with him that i
don't know why i didn't go with him that
day i had something to do all of a
sudden they told me about it i was
[ __ ] i was sick missing the score
like that back then that was a lot of
money you remember tommy had that uh
that one spanish kid in new york in new
york that he got rid of all the stuff
what's his name um alex i think his name
was
his name was alex and we and i was like
oh my god they were selling them for
like maybe 15 20 000 the key back then
real quick
real quick it was amazing how everybody
was going to get robbed at one point
like everybody i did business with
i knew i was going to rob them come on
one point yeah
did you ever get rob joey that's a drug
dealer who
me i did i did i got robbed one time
what happened did you get robbed how
about you they clipped me for seven
grams nothing uh
nothing nothing significant nothing like
that i wrote it off to
you know me dawg you know a thief knows
that things are going to go down if you
keep doing it of course they're going to
have to call it you know
listen man i robbed a lot of blow i
should be shot and hung
for all the blow i robbed and snorted
if i would have been smart i would have
[ __ ] sold it i didn't sell
oh man yeah that's what we did we were
trying to sell it and do it at the time
back then you know what i mean so we had
like four or five guys that were on a
team and we got
got some small ones big ones once in a
while but nothing that was life-changing
yeah we always thought you know 100 keys
100 pounds of weed or something never
got that
you know but it was fun at the time
while it lasted he's going to call out i
didn't go to jail no every [ __ ] time
i talk to you man i get sentimental i
think about your cousin and i think
about uh oh my god and even lubes lubes
we used to get college kids oh my god
we'd sell them coke and then rob the
coke bag
that's a completely different [ __ ]
episode i love you joey he's going to
call in hey i love you lee lee i'm going
to call back but i'm going to see you in
vegas baby all right all right i'm
definitely going to call back coco
500 milligrams of peace that night me
you lean my wife and we're gonna go kill
a [ __ ] strawberry shortcake at the
sports book
i love it i love it science science club
love you bro all right buddy thank you
bye-bye
it makes me [ __ ] my pants just thinking
about the [ __ ] i used to do
i don't [ __ ] around when i tell people
that sometimes i feel so weird sitting
in a room with lee because i don't know
if lee really knew like if you could
look at a film of my life from 80 to 85
if anybody would even listen to me it
was such a [ __ ] horrible education
i'm happy i did it
it made me
the man i am today lee this is some
scary [ __ ] and then i went to prison and
then i still dabbled till 94 and robin
and
i would only take calculated risks i
always knew
you know getting locked up makes you a
better criminal because you learn
different things and i did but i knew
that
if i would have kept on bro and boulder
they were going to nail me again it was
just a matter of time
so i'm going to forget the urge now to
never to go rob somebody never leave
neville because it seemed like you were
getting like super like
like you missed it i'm not missed it but
like it like you guys
sometimes when you talk to give people a
good story you gotta go there yeah and
and when i go there my heart beats and
and i get chills and
i feel shitty about myself
but i like talking about it because it
doesn't make me feel shitty about myself
once i talk about it once i write it out
that's when i feel really bad about
myself the things i did like that but
listen man like i said it wasn't like
i was going up to guys like you these
people dabbled in drugs i dabbled in
drugs everybody knows the [ __ ] cost
when you're dabbling in [ __ ] drugs
man
everybody knows and if you don't know
how is your [ __ ] schooling
you know how was your [ __ ] schooling
so what happened when they got you
no it wasn't like that i got robbed out
of a hotel room one time like that
nothing no no sit down no no no okay
no nothing that exciting no you just
learn you learn the steps you know you
learn what to look for what not to look
for i know who's coming with bad
intentions i know who doesn't have cash
you know
you just learn you just learn these
little [ __ ] things lee
i was [ __ ] up
but you know
i did my time i paid my dues i think
after i got out of prison
i think i did maybe three or four drug
reps after that
i never [ __ ] around with it again man
and i'm very happy i didn't you know i
was telling these guys i i think it's
time to carry a weapon things are
getting bad
you know there's a lot of uh you know
last week in san francisco it was the
shooting
did they still have flowers out on the
pier or anything did you go down there
yeah i didn't see anything but
do you mean like you want to carry up
like a pistol at all times do you think
that's what i want to do i do not want
to carry a pistol but if
you know
random acts the chick got shot in
hollywood the chick got shot in san
francisco last week
you know uh this could be one of us this
could be a podcast listener this could
be anybody man
i get scared lee without the [ __ ]
edibles i get [ __ ] petrified it does
seem to be happening a lot yeah and and
for us to be walking around with not
leaving a piece you're at a park with
your daughter somebody does something i
don't want to shoot nobody lee but
protecting yourself and shooting
somebody is two different [ __ ] worlds
man
knowing you have the ability to protect
yourself
knowing you know i'm not confident in my
[ __ ] i'm no i'm no fighter i can't
fly through the air i'm not [ __ ]
johnny hick what's his name john wick
you know i'm not gonna throw people
through the [ __ ] hair
but
you know you sometimes i get scared man
it's just a natural reaction yeah but i
have a wife and a daughter now
just to play like devil's advocate
wouldn't you also be then scared like
if a lot of people had guns around your
wife and daughter
like that's like that's the only thing
that scares me is if everyone's gonna
start having [ __ ] guns
i don't want to take anyone's money tell
me the truth as a man you're an educated
guy with what you read in the papers and
what you hear
you don't want some type of protection
in your car or in your apartment
you're there with paul or somebody
breaks in they want to do something
you're telling me i got the money you
put two [ __ ] holes in them
i mean what if what if lease no man this
could happen i don't advocate
guns i've told you for 20 years that
they're the worst luck for me that's
what i was gonna say like we were
talking about it earlier
i don't know if i've always heard that
guns attract guns
and yeah it does get [ __ ] scary and
more so i think probably when you have
kids because i was thinking like how can
you send your kid to a public school now
and not be like a little bit worried
but i
i try to keep low key and i i guess i
don't i don't really think i wanted to
man god has a plan or is that at least
that's what they [ __ ] tell you buddha
the jew god hindu they all have a plan
and we all have an expiration day yeah
you know we all have and horrible things
happen in this life
you know and that's why i get bad
thoughts just like everybody else man
and you pray and you fall asleep or
whatever the [ __ ] it is i do get more
protective like if i'm with paula i'm
sure you do like like that whatever yeah
so like i can see you like
before mercy would you have thought
about wanting a gun with just you and i
mentioned it to terry a few times we
live in an area that we're just three
blocks away from life brother yeah we're
a couple blocks away from life
and sometimes bad life goes into good
life and there's nothing you could
[ __ ] do
there's nothing you could do but you
know what man
if you got robbed and you didn't have
protection and you got robbed and you
did have protection how would you feel
how would you feel i mean lee i don't
want you just i'm not going to give you
a gun and you're taking home put under
your pillow i mean that once a week you
go with the agostino go to the range and
shoot and get comfortable with the gun
and you get pretty good at it and you
clean it every three days so it doesn't
jam up on you and
you're not a bad guy you've never had a
bad intention in your heart but what if
we
what if we're at the comedy store one
night you've been thinking that with the
comedy store and a shootout ensues and
i'm there with you
and i got to cover you and i got no
[ __ ] gun what would you do what would
you feel like that you didn't have you
know just a little situation i'm not
saying i'm gonna go buy a gun tomorrow
morning at lisa what i'm saying is that
i don't know i get these thoughts from
time to time just like every [ __ ]
american does
it's like every [ __ ] american
everything every canadian does you know
at one time something happens and it
hits close to home
you know if you wake up tomorrow morning
at 8 in the morning and somebody got
robbed on laurel canyon in ventura how
would you feel yeah they were going to
eat at 9 15 at night that could be you
and paula yeah they totally could okay
no well you know and
red band got rob gump i know
yeah in burbank california the home of
disney where disney pays for undercover
cops and helicopters and [ __ ] cameras
on every block a black wizard came in
the black wizard came
and robbed him you know
now i'm not saying you pulled a gun on
you played charles bronson in death wish
yeah but i'm saying that at least that
fear
you know what it feels like to get
robbed do you have any idea when
something goes down two blocks from you
and you're seeing a gunfight what your
heart happens to your heart no and how
fear takes over it's a horrible [ __ ]
feeling but i know if i got a [ __ ]
gun in my strap and that [ __ ]
comes 10 feet close to me or my daughter
i know i'm gonna [ __ ] unload that
thing and i'm gonna catch with one
bullet i'm gonna tell my daughter and
wife to [ __ ] run
in spanish so the guy don't hear me you
follow me i mean listen i'm just talking
nonsense with you but i literally and i
lived in israel for six months and their
solution to it is
there's a lot more like there's like the
military military everywhere and i know
people are getting upset like there's
too much police everywhere and stuff
like that so i don't think they would go
over here what would that be
like another solution girl got shot in
hollywood what girl where with the girl
that just got shot last week one
comedian's girlfriend
where were the cops when that guy shot
that girl they're getting a bunch of
steam right now in san francisco with us
right we gotta haul go ahead
lou
what's up oh my god we just got off the
phone with joey fulato jesus [ __ ]
christ
how you doing lou
i'm doing all right buddy what about you
good do we ever cross paths
excuse me did we ever cross cross paths
do i remember you from no i don't think
so joe i left i left uh
new jersey in july of 85. this last week
was my 30th anniversary and by that time
you guys five hours
85 hours in the chat
okay
yeah so i i didn't you you were more
friends with darren and uh
joey and i was more friends with joey
for joey joey and joe joey and i and i i
thought danny and for danny uh
danny owed a bookmaker money and the guy
sent me over there to talk to him i said
if you guys you guys are nice guys you
want me to look why don't you come with
me on a few things and you'll be able to
make the money give this guy's money and
get back on your feet they said all
right let's go
and the rest is [ __ ] history yeah
it's
you know we were so crazy at that age
with the blow and the [ __ ] this and
that that
oh my god it was [ __ ] insane it was
like we had a license to do it i mean it
was crazy we didn't care we used to call
it spender tuesday
because for some reason i had a my
father introduced me to this dea agent
and this guy was actually giving us the
scores he was bringing us scores and we
were doing them in there
and it always happened on a tuesday for
some reason he would call me monday
night and say get your boys meet me over
here and we'd go
he gave us search warrants he hooked us
up with bulletproof vests that said dea
on the front
hatch
we told us to wear jeans and a t-shirt
and white sneakers we looked like the
dea
i hate to walk in there and i spoke a
little spanish so
i was able to you know help get you know
get over and the people were flipping
out they couldn't believe it
they were flipping out
where did you grow up at
patterson or wayne jesus christ
patterson or wayne i used to have i went
out with a girlfriend burger that's how
i met
oh joey god you know you think back of
uh i was telling
the podcast and lee
how there's nights you know i smoke pot
and i sit there and i think about
the times you could have got shot and
how lucky you know how lucky you really
[ __ ] are that a bullet didn't go away
i got shot you i got a coco i got shot
oh my god
i was re i was i was over there with the
dea agent
and uh he said to me come on we're gonna
get this guy i go this guy knows us i'm
seven times we got him he knows me as
soon as he keeps me he knows we're not
talking
i'm gonna get shot with this guy go now
listen
i found the stash i know where the guy
is
everything's good we got this so i'm in
the truck sleeping in the van it's 5 30
in the morning he picked me up at a
halfway house i was still in the halfway
house
i'm sitting there in the van
and uh
i'm sleeping and he goes
gone and around the corner comes the guy
we used to go goldfinger because he had
thick rings on every finger a jamaican
kid with rings on every finger and he
had a mr t starter kit around his neck
so
here comes gulping around the corner he
looks in the van he sees me and he goes
oh my god he turns around walks back
around the corner now i had one eye
opener so i look at him and i'm saying
to myself did he recognize me now
so far away he didn't see me
harry trump's back around the corner
with two guys on each side of them they
all got their hands on their shirts and
they start firing they pull out guns and
start firing at the band i put the fan
in drive
push
i put the thing in drive aimed at them
jumped out and i was running behind the
van
i went to get to a tree and my knee gave
out i got shot i didn't even realize i
was behind the tree
i looked down at my knee and said oh my
god i've been hit he was blood put the
knee down it was all blood
so i i said what the hell am i going to
do now so i hear him click click click
he ran out of memo so i come out from
behind the street with a gun i go get on
the ground only this dea guy goes you
ain't no [ __ ] cop and he got up and
ran away
goes you better get out of here
and i said oh my god now i gotta limp
out of here i started lifting away
lifting away i hop over a fence and
behind this building i see uh harlem
river drive so i started hopping my way
down to harlem river drive
i fall down a few times because it hurts
and i keep rubbing my leg and i keep
rubbing my hair get my hair out of my
eyes because i'm loving my
i'm rubbing the hair i got blood all
over my face i don't realize it because
i'm alone
and
the guy that the dd agent my father told
me was a killer it's got the killer
copper he'll be able to be there for you
for everything he jumped in a band and
drove away
he left me there
so i'm coming down the hill i get to
harlem river drive
and i hop over the fence and i and and i
i hear the cops coming i hear the sirens
coming like oh i got to get rid of this
gun and his badge i throw it in the east
river i'm sitting down on a guardrail
and two minutes later there was like six
cops there and then get up get over here
i go
maybe you're not looking real good i've
been shot i got shot in the leg i can't
get over there they pick me up throw me
in the squad car
and they take me to harlem hospital two
blocks away
and i'm in the harlem hospital and uh
they're like oh my god you guys shot
they must have thought you were a cop
i go i don't know what happened i was
over here to rehab a building i'm
working for one of my father's friends
who's buying buildings we rehab them
and uh when we're done he sells them
whatever rents him
i go i was sitting in the van the guy
started firing at the van
he goes oh they thought you were a cop
make the long story short
uh
the cops they brought me to a room uh
that they suck
antibiotics in my leg
and then they uh
they patched me up
they gave me a segment that sent me to
my room
they sent me to a room and i i climbed
off the bed the cops were there i made
her that was falling asleep they were
trying to question me i fell asleep i
made when i was falling asleep they left
i crawled out of out of the bed got in a
wheelchair
rolled down the hallway if there was
like five fifteen old ladies
in line for uh
for the phone i said lady sweet i'm a
police officer i just got shot i gotta
call my house you got my wife fell oh no
problem they left me right on the phone
i got on the phone i called
joey i said joey up in room 616 get the
van get danny come get me
i went back to the room jumped in the
bed and closed my eyes when i held my
eyes there was standing there
i was okay let's get out of here
that was it
lou that was like the hotbed
i had a i had spent my summers
i'm a cuban i used to spend my summers
on 148th
and broadway my stepfather shot a dude
with santeria guys and [ __ ] but i became
friends with the cedeno family
and they had not puerto rican kids and
they had nine kids and the one that was
my age you know i had i had kept in
touch with them through the years from
the time we were six to 18. but i saw
him once i went over to the cop and you
know that was the
for people who don't know in the 80s and
the 90s
from i think it started like on i don't
even know lou 108th street and all the
way up on every [ __ ] street somebody
sold drugs
right or wrong
135th
143.
it's ridiculous how many spots there
were
i used to love the mom and pop bodegas
there i used to go there every week if
you eat the food i love the cuban
dominican puerto rican food i mean
that's me i go down i still go to union
city i go to las palmas in new york city
and i still go here my wife's going to
go there oh can i go to all the time
i'm in miami a lot you know before the
fight goes into i promote now but uh are
you friends with vinnie curtis
i know
very well finney's out here with me he's
a he's [ __ ] nuts i talk to him once a
month you know to tell me i know oh i
love him like a brother in fact i'm
going to try to get him back on the
podcast but it's so much drama he got to
get a ride here he forgets the address
he forgets my name hey ask him what he
did
hey listen come on don't say i said it
but after what he did
when uh they they matched him up with
marvin hagler he took off for florida
they sold out the boston garden all the
white guys up there
they sold out the boston guard
they had turtle
they sold out the garden they said oh my
god we're going to make a ton of money
turtle took off
he said i'm not going to fight this guy
he took off
and they had to give everybody back
their
money turtle was in miami with angelo
dunphy and
uh chris dundee and he was fighting down
here with the same manager i had i had
my manager's name was murray gaby
and colonel had the same manager
how crazy
is the boxing business
well you know
foxy itself i mean not everybody's at
mayweather not everybody's gonna make
that kind of money
but
it's a good stepping stone if you're if
you're a good athlete
and you you know how to use your hands
and you have good brain to your good you
know you're good to your body
you can make a money you can make money
to
make it make a life for yourself
but if you throw in it for a career and
you're going to stay there forever and
you're going to box for until you're 50
or 40 or 50 hey you know you're going to
start talking to guys
so
bell's going to ring you the duck
because the guy's gonna start swinging
action
but uh
it's it's a great sport
i mean look at mma corporal look at mma
i mean uh joe broke is a great guy but
mma in the ufc
those guys don't make a quarter a
quarter of what boxers make
they don't make a quarter of it and who
wants to get in there and work and get
kicked get punched in the head get
kicked get uh
elbowed in the face in the back of the
head feet in the chest and the stomach i
mean all that stuff for
the little by the money they get
i mean i just don't i just don't
understand it i mean if you can use your
hands stand up and box you make it
three four five times the money why
would you get that on it don't get me
wrong i like mma i watch it it's a it's
a lot of fun i mean you know and they
call boxing barbaric i'm like oh you're
kidding me right we wear 10 ounce gloves
they wear 10 12 ounce gloves heavy
weights and they wear or 10 ounce
heavyweights i'm thinking about the
amateurs but 10 ounce gloves in the pros
and they wear four ounce drugs let me
hit somebody with a four ounce plot of
cocoa and i'm 62 years old i'll kill
them
they will never be they will never get
up
if i hit somebody with a left hook with
a four ounce glove on it's over
i just got done spawning just now with
my client
you know naca foley's out here too right
huh you know a guy named naca foley
yeah only yeah a boxing guy from boston
good guy he's about your age vietnam yes
he's out here he has he's at justin
fortune's gym he's that justin fortune's
a guy that trains uh pacquiao the new
he was the old strength and conditioning
and now he came back after uh uh rivas
or silva whatever the guy's name was
quit or got into the beef with uh
with pacquiao's trainer
oh
did you see the uh the fight in mexico
that just happened or no in the
philippines with like the mexican
politician
who had like a really oh yeah what
happened with that
this dude who apparently had like chest
implants to
pay this like chubby intern dude
to like
throw a fight he got like barely tapped
and the guy went down
it was pretty hysterical they said they
just
and even the announcers are saying like
oh this guy was just done for a favor
for somebody he does business with
it was crazy what about the sermon fight
did you see the thurman fight no
me neither i don't watch
got hit with a body shot
and he almost crumbled but see his
glimpse on his face he was really hurt
and bad he went down he went down to one
knee it got up
he got up the referee didn't even count
him because he got right back up and
they started playing again and knocked
his opponent down 30 seconds later
that's what you do when you're in pain
yep it's time to go let's give it this
guy now it's i gotta go it's funny i've
been hearing about you for a long time
and you know danny's
i don't you know i grew up with those
guys and it was uh i think back of those
days when we were like just talking to
joey before
you know uh you get these [ __ ]
goosebumps i get anxiety that
those people didn't come looking
that those people didn't even come
looking for us
like uh yeah yeah yeah he's not he's not
saying we listen we did so many jobs we
one night we went to a place called
fuego fuego in in uh fuego laid off a
broadway broadway over there in the city
it was a dominican in the nightclubs
lego playground but right the same
morning
that morning we were off the dominicans
we got them for like 10 keys and about
80 000 in cash so we got rid of this
stuff and we
everybody got their money we're all
going out and bought suits we go out and
buy suits and the shoes it was a tuesday
was a little buying all clothes we meet
we go out with two fuego fuego we're in
fuego fuego in uh in the bronx there or
not the bronx upper manhattan before the
bridge and we're dancing i'm dancing
with this dominican girl and all of a
sudden joey goes up there and goes lily
to your right i look to the right if he
goes towards him guys we got this
morning they're all sitting at a table
i go oh my god there they are i go
waitress come here over and send the
bubble without bringing you onto those
guys
and tell them it's from me
point to me so she said okay she takes
the bottle of dumplings over there puts
table and points at me they go oh my god
there's that cop they ran out of the
place
so he goes you are crazy i go look at
joe they never let them not think what
stops when we leave
you make them think we're cops we're
giving them a break
you know we're right we're not going to
arrest them we're taking their stuff
we're not the rest of them and they'll
uh you know they'll think that and we're
cool i played a cop two times i could
never play a cop
i was telling joey i handcuffed twice or
three times i handcuffed people it's
horrible the first time i had a handcuff
a guy i almost [ __ ] my pants i know i
farted
i know i thought it for sure as i was
bending over putting the handcuffs on
that's a horrible thing to do
they're shaking
you got your knee on their leg they're
shaking oh it's [ __ ] terrible
when i got caught
they're laying down on the ground we
used to walk in i used to handcuff
everybody because i you know i mean i
saw scarface i ain't looking to get
killed put everybody down you know and i
love joey and i love danny and but
they're they was a little hyper at the
time and i told him look guys
i i i don't want i had to give him a gun
but i was scared to death to give it to
him you know joey especially joey he's a
great kid but he'll shoot somebody in a
second joe you got to be like so joe you
got to relax
well that was the biggest fear
that was the biggest fear i had
whenever i had a weapon in my hand jesus
[ __ ] christ
you know and i went away for kidnapping
and even that day i remember having the
weapon in my hand
and just dying inside because i knew
that something this gun goes off
we were just talking about me buying a
gun now you know
because the [ __ ] uh lou the world's
going as [ __ ]
oh no you gotta have a gun you gotta
keep gotta have you gotta keep your
family safe yeah and you gotta have
something oh my god the best weapon is a
shotgun coco i just buy a 12 gauge
keep it in the house i just want to make
it pretty good i'm not
pro or anti-gun control i don't care
what people have i'm saying were asking
me if i wanted a gun that's all i wanted
like i'm i don't care what other people
no no no we were discussing yeah having
a gun to how i always
at one age lou i think
i think after the after i got out for
the kidnapping i i got rid of all the
guns i didn't want any more i knew that
they had brought me just having the gun
on me
would make my body language different
and people that carrie can tell when
somebody else is carrying
it's a weirdo
i'm not allowed to own a gun so i'm not
worried about it i mean i'm like you
mean i'm not allowed to own a gun either
i could just have a bazooka
with [ __ ] night goggles and [ __ ]
would you have to like petition them
yeah i'd have to go back to court but it
was over my felony was over 10 years ago
so i'm okay i can get him back then you
can get it you can get you can get what
they call expunged sure you gotta make
money
but who wants a weapon on paper you want
to have 92 of them that are [ __ ]
dirty so you can blast them and [ __ ]
i don't know who shot him somebody up
the corner
i don't know what was that lou i got to
let you go but i want you to call in
again when we have more time brother
i definitely will i love you guys i love
you we'll be watching for you friday
night on showtime tell them what time
i'll be there i'll be there around i
think it's around uh the fights start at
seven uh tv probably go on around 9 30.
okay we'll be watching for you and
cheering for you my brother
thank you pal have a good day
see if you people just tuned in this was
the criminal version of the church of
what's happening now when we talk about
robbing people and [ __ ] handcuffing
people and having a good time and
getting weapons and [ __ ] we don't
usually talk about this today it was
just today uh i got a couple emails two
weeks ago and last week about it and uh
it just seemed [ __ ] scary to me that
people want to hear about this nonsense
you know i'm saying
let me give some shout outs
oh [ __ ] it's monday thank you lee
i've gone shooting a couple times
it's fun
i know you have the true
what the [ __ ] lee what's up buddy what
the [ __ ]
that's uh
john wolf g you know i love you brandy
lynn looking better and better i'm going
to see in a few weeks
davin christensen
ollie [ __ ] uh ali buzz down in
australia i haven't heard from you got
me worried my man dante gazzini always
writing this guy writes more letters in
the declaration of independence dj
dorchester
johnny arch
and jason monterey i love you
[ __ ]
what's up with you lee
so you should have gone to original
joe's you [ __ ] up
every time you go into san jose
san francisco you got to go catch one
meal original judge
i got a really really great burrito
oh that's [ __ ] fantastic
yeah
i forget the name of the place
but it was a scary neighborhood
but it was delicious what type of
burrito was it uh
you loved that connie assad
and she got like a
quesadilla squeezer or something like
they put like the meat and stuff inside
the quesadilla
you went two thousand miles to eat
mexican freezer and shots
you didn't go to original joe's you had
bubble gum like ari like that dudes and
butts
who's in that place he got his eyes
fixed today so i got to call him a
little if if you are ever up there mercy
would love that place what is it candy i
think i want to give her [ __ ] candy
and get a star no they have they have
their berries and all that [ __ ] kind of
berries everything like real fruit
better that's a [ __ ] confectionery
real no amazing delicious fresh yeah and
they got they got peacocks walking
around and they got train rides and so
you went there to get candy you said i
did that's what i got yeah
oh i got yogurt pretzels i love them
that's so good but they're so bad for
you so you went to san francisco they
get yogurt no i got that on the way
there you see what i deal with people i
also got almonds covered in the original
joes he got almonds he went on an
italian tour listen who goes on a
[ __ ] italian tour after all we talk
about the last thing i want you to make
believe is to walk around like a dunce
like a tourist yeah
holding hands like you take pictures too
yeah oh jesus christ what am i gonna do
with you
we walked all the way up lombard that
was hard did you walk all the way that's
why you even the stairs
did you really yeah no anxiety attacks
no
oh that's good for you
paul didn't like going down the hill
though that was funny she got really
cause she got kind of nervous what's he
going to do stay up there and [ __ ] yo
who no
walk down
[ __ ] walk down that's what i need to
talk about right
what am i going to do with you a [ __ ]
attack well we gave you the italian tour
as a gift paula why would she do it what
is it
italian tour will they give you the food
yeah what kind of food we went and we
got chocolate truffles all right
uh from this really cool place like xlx
something and you're going to different
restaurants yeah because i saw houses
what the [ __ ] was that picture of oh
that's the full house houses
i i watched it as a kid it was cool to
see it are you [ __ ] putting me on
right now that was a full house house
that you put the picture of right now
yeah it's cool
you said i gotta deal with people and
then you people get mad you say you pick
on lee i'm trying to help this
[ __ ] i didn't do anything i saw
it a little cool picture thing though i
wanted a [ __ ] italian no it wasn't a
picture of a [ __ ] house oh and then
we did the the bikes those were fun but
scary bikes did you have your helmet on
no they didn't give you helmets and they
were putting you on roads with like cars
on them
it was it was in golden gate bridge park
i'm so next time you go away i'm gonna
[ __ ] have somebody mug you just
principal
just if you see him on a bike just knock
him in her off the [ __ ] bike it's
over let him [ __ ] sue him and collect
the settlement we'll take care of him
we'll patch him up
italian tour what else did they feed you
yeah what kind of food did you eat uh
pizza from this place all right
it's really apparently really good um
it's across the street from original
joe's all right um we got and then we
got pasta
from this other place all right and uh
and then we got cannolis they were good
look at you you had a good time and
that's all that meant how many years
you've been with her now
look at you when i first met you you had
[ __ ] staminkia living with you you
wouldn't either ask me she was sleeping
now you've been with this beautiful
mexican girl for two years you're gonna
get what are you gonna propose this
christmas like a half a fact no
when
i kind of want to live with someone
before i propose is she gonna live with
her in sin
[ __ ]
yeah
i think i i i think it's important to
see if we match living together
well what do you think when she comes
over does she [ __ ] in the bathroom
yeah what's it smell like
fine and you live with it yeah
but it's different it's not different
that's it they come over they [ __ ] you
see how they live they do the dishes do
they leave them there
they leave [ __ ] out you got to clean up
after it's all those things that matter
do you have to [ __ ] tele underlay
here
you know this is in your [ __ ] nature
to clean get it together here i got to
bring a lady in for 40 hours a week to
clean for your [ __ ] ass get up clean
this [ __ ] house the vacuum
everything's waiting for you
that wouldn't that go well with her well
that's the problem then that's the end
well how you gonna live with it that's
not gonna go well with it because she'll
wanna do the person coming in no there's
no person coming in when a woman lives
in the house
oh
that's just just a natural thing what
woman's gonna after you take a [ __ ] and
you leave that [ __ ] thing what woman's
gonna leave that in that's your home
no woman that lives in a home listen a
man could be a filthy pig a woman ain't
got time to be a dirty [ __ ] animal
what woman cannot see that what woman if
you did something that was there for two
days you're gonna wait for some lady to
come in that's what you're trying to
tell me
what's like what
whoa lady comes in what once a week
she comes once and like every month and
a half right so what does this girl do
for the other month and a half just let
the laundry pile up and everything pile
up oh no we do laundry you got to clean
you got to underlay mop and get the
[ __ ] vacuum and you got to do the
room and the [ __ ] shower curtains and
you know there's a much that you could
do but if you don't tell them to do it
they're never gonna do it then what are
you gonna do you're gonna live around a
cleaning lady
men could be [ __ ] filthy pigs women
cannot be [ __ ] pigs
a woman has to pick up that piece of
paper if she sees it even if she didn't
[ __ ] do it you know what i'm saying
or she could tell you to do it
yeah but that's the number one thing
that they [ __ ] clean a little
everybody's gotta chip in
but if you're gonna eat burritos and
leave the dish on the table and i gotta
pick it up for you i don't want you
around
right or wrong yeah i don't want nobody
around that don't do handle this [ __ ]
if you're a woman and i go out to
[ __ ] uh i was talking to somebody
that was going through a divorce and he
said that what bothered him the most is
when he got home there wasn't dinner
made because how can you live like that
you're a man's out your man's doing [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] but you know well
i've started to think about that man and
i just like it's like
how
how can i ex like expect like paula
wanted to that'd be great but like i
don't know how to ask someone like to
expect like yeah we're living together
you're going to cook
i don't know got it what the [ __ ] that's
what women do
what they can't go to eat out every
[ __ ] night
you got listen let me tell you a little
story i'ma tell you a very important
story that irks me every day because i
miss this kid more than you'd ever know
when i first got it he used to be
friends with this [ __ ] samina kid
gavin
but gavin had a half a more friend named
keith and i like keith he came down here
to be a comic
yeah he used to hum
when he think he'd hum hmm
we used to call him the hummer
and he was insecure and he had his
insecurities so i'm insecure so i know
what it feels like to be insecure and i
took a liking to him
i loved him he was a freak
but he was the nicest guy in the world
and people always took advantage of this
[ __ ] guy
in fact he let girls stay at his house
that he was in love with like they were
in a bind and then the girls would move
in guys and [ __ ] in front of them it was
horrible the guy was a stepping stone
and i never raised my hand i never
said anything to him i used to talk to
gavin about it and go you got to talk to
him because i didn't grow up with him
you did
you did you have to talk to him you know
and we go out to lunch man three times a
week this kid worked part-time and
probably made 120 grand a year as a tv
installer [ __ ] smart as a whip man
smart as a [ __ ] whip
and he had some dirty [ __ ] living with
man that he would [ __ ] in the ass and
take pictures and [ __ ] but
they would move a boyfriend in for like
a month until they got their life
together it was [ __ ] horrible
and we talked to them we get them high
they come to the comedy store and hang
out with me i really like them
i tried to be extra nice to him like if
i borrowed money from him i'd pay him
back when i told him
he used to lend me money for coke i tell
him the truth this is for coke and he
told me he didn't want to do it but he
still give it to me
and i made sure i always paid him on
time because everybody else wouldn't pay
him at all
i went out of my way to
uh
not do what everybody else did to this
guy
and i know that everybody beat on him as
a as a floor match so i never really
said nothing about his personal life
even though it bothered the [ __ ] out of
me you know me
one day he comes to me he gets sent on a
blind date
he gets sent on a blind date with a
doctor
he's making 120 130 000 a year he lives
good he's got every movie on dvd he's
got big screen you go to his house dog
jesus christ it's like better than a
movie theater or i would go over and see
heat the shooting scene okay we'd smoke
dope on his balcony and just watch the
heat the shooting scene
but you mean i love this guy if i got to
say the top 10 people i met in my life i
loved him
and i wanted everything good fun and he
hooked up with he got put on a blind
date and she was a big time doctor and
she made two million a year
and
me and him were tight he was chubby
so and i used to go eat
and i knew
what we used to eat and i know what he
did with this guy and i know
me and him got along the way we did
because we both yucked
a lot of foods
like we would not even think of eating a
lot of a lot of foods right you know we
would not his big thing was almonds
he doesn't like almonds no he loved
dominance okay i love almond diamonds
just grateful and no cancer you know
and i love this [ __ ] i love this
dude you know
but he meets this girl and now he's
telling me how he's going to eat like
korean tongue
and all this [ __ ] and i'm looking at
this guy and i'm looking at him lee
and i can see that he's breaking
more and more
in front of me with this woman but i'm
not saying nothing
i [ __ ] hate this chick i don't
[ __ ] like her at all to the point
where he proposes to where he's gonna
marry it
i'm like i'm not even going to the
[ __ ] wedding i booked myself out that
week purposely
because
i loved him
and i didn't think he was ready for a
wedding and i didn't think that
i just knew this wasn't going nowhere i
just knew that this was bad
well this [ __ ] married him and
she got pregnant right away
and guess what she told me
she goes after i have the kid i don't
give a [ __ ] about your job i'm not
getting up with this kid at night
you're getting up with this [ __ ] kid
and i got to get to work you know why
because i make 2 million a year i don't
give a [ __ ] about your job now even if
she didn't have a job she had a job that
paid her three-quarters of a million
dollars a year just overlooking
uh medical
papers for civil lawsuits and [ __ ] like
that okay seven to five
and when he came to me i go dog
i could live off 750.
now she was korean and she was dirt
cheap
you want me to talk to you about dirt
cheap hell yeah no tv
no cable
no air conditioning
do they hate fun i don't bro this was
hard
oh i needed a house come to me and tell
me this lee and you know me lee i'm like
i'm not gonna listen to this what did
they do they would no no and then i i
don't know what was going on
i don't know what was going on so one
day
i i just couldn't take when he told me
this stuff we would meet three times a
week for at least breakfast we'd meet at
the ihop across from the in and out in
hollywood
next to the sneaker warehouse there and
one day this [ __ ] is telling me
all this [ __ ] how he doesn't have a job
you know uh oh and he is the best he had
to take care of her mother
lee they had no air conditioning
that no air conditioning no cable tv no
tv at all
this kid lived on tv
you don't [ __ ] understand
he had to watch the kid at night change
the diapers and then watch the kid in
the daytime until a nanny came at like
two o'clock then he could work for three
hours but if the mother needed to take a
bath or something he'd have to bathe the
mother
lee this was my insides were on fire and
one day
i told my friend that was close with him
by this time i had a relationship with
the kid
and i [ __ ] i think me and ralphie may
talk to him
well a week later he stopped talking
around for me
and about a week after that he stopped
talking to me because we told him lee
you gotta get some type of
uh wait uh keith you gotta get some type
of semblance in your life you have to
catch this because it's getting worse
you know what he's doing today
what
she divorced and left him for a doctor
and he lives downstairs in the bottom
apartment
with another loser buddy of his who's
still writing mrs.fire too
because he was waiting for [ __ ] robin
williams to do mrs.fire too
they live in a basement he got his
tv
business going again because he got a
nanny for the baby but he pretty much
has the baby 24 hours a [ __ ] day and
he has to live downstairs and listen to
his wife
getting [ __ ] by another [ __ ] man
he sent me a message a month ago
you know what that message was
i should listen to you i'm sorry and i
love you i haven't heard back from i
haven't told anybody at all not even my
wife
i haven't contacted him because
that's what happened
i talked to him
they got mad at me
you gotta take control somewhere
if you don't tell this person that you
love what you feel and what you expect
from them it's not gonna go nowhere
it's gonna happen 10 years too late
do you follow the sandy you don't have
to back like a butcher
but you have to stick up for yourself in
every relationship
if you gotta [ __ ] live with it before
you marry her what the [ __ ] are you
marrying her for that
you wanna do you wanna you wanna demo
drive or some [ __ ]
i guess
no she's giving you a demo drive right
now
yeah
well she can't she can't uh
she can't move out until she graduates
anyway so
she's going to have expectations from
you
and you're going to have expectations
from her that's in her relationship yeah
but if you don't raise your [ __ ] hand
you know wanna comes over mondays and
fridays
to watch mercy when terry run out runs
errands okay okay
who do you think cleans the house
from tuesday to friday you think the
dishes just stay there
and the kitchen just
we do
no yeah of course you do you know you
just can't sit on the couch and vegetate
everybody gotta kick in here no no you
gotta do dishes and everybody gotta cook
because you can't do 40 a night every
night right that's 280 a week 40 a
[ __ ] night
so somebody's got to get a cookbook and
somebody's got to learn how to flip
those [ __ ] tacos
because if not what's the use what's the
[ __ ] use
what am i getting [ __ ] married for
you following me
you know
a man has to respect a woman and a woman
has to respect a man
you know and they have to make it fit
somewhere along the line but
you know what you don't know how to cook
i don't give a [ __ ]
you got to [ __ ] learn you got it
right or wrong you got you know hey
listen my mom taught me how to do
laundry
so whenever i see my baskets filled i
pick it up and take it downstairs but
i'm not doing my wife's [ __ ] laundry
you kabish were you following me yeah we
both kick in but everybody gotta kick in
you just can't sit there and fan and go
and
i've never been this far into like a
relationship before oh i know you
haven't but you have to raise your hand
from time to time and go i ain't going
for that you know when i got off the
phone with you and you're not going to
believe this
i didn't think about the keith thing
until you told me the other day you took
the picture of original joe's and i said
are you going to go and you go i don't
have to sell it to paul
and right there i knew
you didn't have to sell it we're going
to original joe's well it doesn't matter
because it's the best value in town for
the dollar
i'm going to take you to where [ __ ]
dean martin used to come up here with
sinatra you want to take me on some
italian tour with some of these fake
[ __ ] that sell for cachio bread
no
i'm taking you to where it all started
right or wrong that's the 40 [ __ ]
years they've been there 60 [ __ ]
years they've been there well there's no
convincing you just go
let's go where are we going we're going
to go inside and eat but but nothing
gets sit down
there's someone in a chicken parmesan a
french fry
something but you got to eat here you
come up here for 50 [ __ ] years you
know what i'm saying i'm not a savage
every day tonight uh terry's having a
bad day so the dryer broke
you know she was at the zoo with the
baby and she got the call and then she
had to come back and we had to drive
wanna and then we had to all go together
and i had to take the baby to the dryer
mat and dry the clothes and
you know so i told like oh don't worry
about nothing we're going to go [ __ ]
when i go home i have a short list of
where we're going to go but she's not
going to make me eat something that i
don't [ __ ] like
or i don't want to [ __ ] eat you know
she's going to go i'm in the mood for
this
there's something like what i'm saying
but there's sometimes i can't [ __ ]
step in there and you're not gonna have
disagreements but you're gonna have
boundaries in the relationship
okay
right yeah i don't know i'm asking you i
don't know it's um
it's just the
if you like in the old i don't know if
it's old enough i don't know what the
the the word is
relationships
that yeah the wife cooks and my mom
cooked and and her mom cooks and
everyone's mom's cooked but
it's never been discussed paul's cooked
for me a lot and she does like to cook
for me but it isn't like an every
day thing
and i don't
i don't want to have her sick cook every
day
but i've also been like
if we get married does that how does
that revert because you've talked about
it with your first marriage you said you
got like married to
get somebody to do your laundry or
something
i'm like does that happen and i'm like
i i don't know how that was young and i
was dumb well no i didn't know what to
expect i've listened i've always been
the type of guy i don't want a woman
looking at my underwear i don't want to
be looking at my underwear right i just
smelled my shoe before i'm eight feet
away from my shoe you think i won't want
somebody washing my socks you're
following me so i always been the type
of guy that's very
impersonal when i go to a woman's house
when i go to somebody's house
let's let's talk about it when i go to
somebody's house and i go to pee
if there's a man or woman that lived in
that bathroom isn't impeccable
i don't look i don't even look in her
[ __ ] face anymore
you're following me if i go into your
bathroom there's a pair of panties
backwards and i see a skid mark on that
[ __ ] yellow stain a pee or something
that's happened to me i've gone to
people's homes and i've gotten the
bathroom to pee and in the bathroom on
the floor there's a woman's underwear
with a yellow mark and a snatch
i won't even touch the crackers
i won't even taste the [ __ ] dip
because if you don't have the chance to
pick your [ __ ] underwear up what am i
gonna do there and i've done dog i've
done it i've gone to people's houses
that have had money
and i've had to go into that bathroom
and i've been in shock that a woman
lives there
geez like that a woman puts her [ __ ]
hot little [ __ ] on that toilet with pee
on it
like yellow pee on the [ __ ] thing
that anybody would look at that and wipe
it down that's what i'm saying at one
point do you walk past something i don't
know i agree with that it's just it's
just it's a weird
i don't know how you would just go to
how assuming they do it that's all how
does somebody walk past something
and see it there how do how many you
know i'm a firm believer i don't ever
want you to come to my house and see a
dish in myself
that's the biggest disrespect you could
do to somebody is me coming to your
house and see six dishes in the same i
don't want to see that though
and i don't ever want you to come to my
house and we see that unless we're just
cooking and eating that's just me
i'm from the school that you finish a
dish you get the [ __ ] up with that dish
and you that's me i get up with my dish
every night i don't think terry has
never brought me a dish or taking a dish
unless you're over and she's like bring
it in but besides that if you're not
over something i get up and get that
food myself and when i finish i get up i
rinse the [ __ ] dish
in my house i had to rinse the [ __ ]
dish
and even if i didn't wash it i had to
rinse it to help out the dude or the
woman who was washing it
i go to your house to eat tonight with
your mother when i was in high school i
pick up myself and i put the dish in the
sink
and i hit it with water and they'll say
leave it there and then i leave it there
but i don't know what anybody else was
raised that's how i was raised i i never
did the water thing but yeah i always i
always hit a dish of water really yeah
always why let the cheat this is easy
this is pre-soaking i don't know what
plans they have for the sink what time i
don't know why like maybe they want to
do something with the sink i never know
where to put the plate
where to put the plate yeah but you soak
the [ __ ] plate for them okay you soak
it for them if i'm eating uh if i if i
cook something and it's got a film i
[ __ ] put it in the sink and you soak
it for somebody and you hit it with soap
with hot water
that's very good and now later on when
they come in
the [ __ ] [ __ ] is done
i've been to people's houses and there's
a stack of [ __ ] dishes and fruit
flies i run out of that mm-hmm
yeah
yeah i know but i but i've always been
alone so i've always done all of my
cleaning
so it's just now that it's going to be
where we we're going to move in kind of
soon and be like how does it
i just i don't know if it just happens
is it like did we talk about it i don't
know
well next week when she comes over
[ __ ] put some dishes out if she don't
pick him up anything i ever talk with
what the [ __ ] you sat here for two days
and then pick that [ __ ] glass up what
are you doing with your life
right or wrong
when you're when you're showering she
should come out throw some coffee on for
[ __ ] lee
and uh what the [ __ ] is going on with
this little house why is this house
smell like this oh he left the dish up
you come out you see that she's doing
that you take the vacuum
that's what a couple does
yeah but i'm gonna see you walk past the
dish 18 times with an ice cream cup you
left there you better get the [ __ ] up
you better check yourself
and check who the [ __ ]
the [ __ ]
right or wrong i don't know i don't
[ __ ] know i'm not talking about being
i don't know either an animal but
you got to say something
somebody's got to say something she's
not messy around my house no
so yeah i don't know i've just been
thinking about it i wonder what other
people when you wake up and go in the
shower she make your bed
no it'll make the bed you got to make
the bed that's number one who makes the
bed well
that's what somebody on the natch would
do got to make the bed i just [ __ ] in
that [ __ ] bed i'm gonna get in that
bed without you know what i'm saying
right or wrong i don't know i i never
care about baby
dog
the bed's got to be made you're going to
jump into an unmade bed hell yeah oh
that's disgusting why because it's
[ __ ] disgusting
no well let me ask you do you wipe your
ass after your [ __ ] every time yes well
what you gotta do the same thing with
the bed it's gotta look nice when you
jump in the sheets are fresh you spray
some febreze in that [ __ ]
when i get up in the morning after i
wash my little monkey and i do the
tweets and [ __ ] i turn around i put the
bed back up i fold it over you move the
pillows you get them nice and nice
you take a little bit more seriously
than i do absolutely you want to live
like a doctor right
i have a good shoe listen man i've been
poor so the the two pillows i had i had
to make work all those years
yeah so you [ __ ] fluff them back the
[ __ ] up and you spray some febreze on
those [ __ ] so you can hit that
pillow with bad breath all over again
for your [ __ ] hours
relationships are tough man and
you have to say something those are
disagreements come it's not what you say
it's how you say it
you can't say you [ __ ] animal clean
the house yeah but you could say
you [ __ ] animal clean the house in
different ways what is that
anyway
our sponsors let's give a big shout out
to honor.com the [ __ ] masters
and uh
tropics that's the [ __ ] word i always
get stuck people you know me i'm no
[ __ ] phi beta kappa
complete earth grown nootropics with
alpha gpc ac 11 alpha brand is really
making it happen
the thing i love the most about this
whole company is with alpha brain they
give you 100 money back guarantee
and when somebody has that type of
guarantee we don't want the product back
i believe in it okay it's like michael
jordan even if michael jordan scores 40
you defend against the other four
[ __ ] morons and michael jordan's
always going to score 40.
i don't even know what i mean by that
you got to eat what i ate today i was
with you buddy i don't know you want to
get half of that cookie though no we
already ate half of that it has the best
stuff the best thing to do with on it
even after i talk about anybody talks
about it just go to honey.com just take
a chance go check out the hemp protein
go check out the the shroom tech sport
the shroom tech uh
immune go check out the coconut oil for
the coffees and whatnot go check out the
the tea the testosterone booster they
have an array of products that are going
to rock your world but listen don't take
it from me go to just start with alpha
brain go to on it right now and press in
church and get 10 off your first order
okay order alpha brain give it a shot
you're gonna have some dark [ __ ]
nightmares which are nice to have
colored dreams but after a few weeks
you're gonna feel so much better the
focus is gonna come on you're gonna go
what the [ __ ] made me think of that
please give it a shot 100 money back
guarantee what the [ __ ] are you getting
all right number two hit e6
from the beautiful cigars to the
beautiful e-cigs 1200 guaranteed [ __ ]
pups you go to one of these isis
7-elevens what do they give you they
give you one of those sticks what do you
get ten [ __ ] puffs for ten dollars
right now 86 is running a special 5 for
50 bucks that's 10 bucks a [ __ ] piece
1200 guaranteed hits this [ __ ]
cigar has been going for three to four
weeks growing strong am i bullshittingly
you know [ __ ] enjoy
hmm
look at the clouds i'm blowing like bob
marley you understand me but don't
[ __ ] take it from me
go to hit e6 right now and press in
joey's church and get five for five so
what you do is you get five for fifty
you get two cigars and you get yourself
the 24 milligram cigarette the eight to
the 16 and get the zero just cut the
eight out you're just wasting your time
it's like air with [ __ ] whatever and
the two cigars you hold on to them you
go to vegas atlantic city you can blow
smoke and [ __ ] faces you know what
i'm saying
anybody could blow smoke blow that hit
e-cig [ __ ] blow and smoke in some
[ __ ] eyeball see what happens to it
[ __ ] starts twitching and [ __ ] she
goes into convulsions anyway go to heavy
six right now and press in joey's shirt
boom and get yourself five for fifty
right now all right and to my [ __ ]
goombas from [ __ ] uh west new york
new jersey mike cubans i love you
[ __ ]
nailed it life those gummies are mono
whether it's the goomies or the little
[ __ ] white chocolate patties they
gave us last time you're going down you
understand me you're going [ __ ] down
like rory mcdonald like [ __ ] holding
on to yeah
that was a great [ __ ] fight but
anyway go to nailthelife.com and take a
look at all the stuff the vapers take a
look at their vapor pen they have so
many great things on that web page
they're the master of the dab you
understand me if you like dabbing these
are the [ __ ] you want to run
with go to nail to life.com and press in
joey diaz boom
and get 20 off your vapor pen and also
go to iron dragon tv for classic martial
arts preston joey boom and get two free
films on the [ __ ] cuff for mine
dragon tv alright beside that we'll be
back wednesday for our 300th episode
we'll be at 2 o'clock pacific 5 o'clock
east coast
wait who
sadiq i love you guys stay black have a
great [ __ ] two days thank you for
listening to this gibberish tonight was
tremendous
what are you looking at lee put on john
lennon let's get this party started all
right we're doing it
huh we're doing it buddy we're doing
what
look at the shape you can't even [ __ ]
talk